[Musique]
David Bavrez, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Alors, je suis
David Bavret. Je suis à la
fois investisseur et
essayiste. J'ai travaillé pendant 15 ans
à Londres dans la finance et ça fait une
douzaine d'années que je vis à Hong Kong
et je partage mon temps à peu près 2
tiers Hong Kong et un tiers en l'Europe.
Donc quand je suis à Paris, je suis
essayiste parce que dire que je suis
investisseur, c'est comme je dirais que
je suis négrier colonialiste, ce serait
serait mieux. Et puis quand je suis à
Hong Kong, ben je suis investisseur
parce que quand je dis je suis, j'ai cré
des bouquins, les Hong Kong il me dit
"Mais ça rapporte de l'argent ?" Je dis
"Bah non, il me dit mais tu dois
vraiment être un mauvais investisseur."
Donc je suis un peu schizophrène. L'idée
c'est de mélanger les
deux et mon côté investisseur c'est de
d'essayer de donc je suis essay
j'essaye, j'essaie de comprendre le
monde tel qu'il est, même quand il me
plaît pas. Donc je pose la question
pourquoi une fois, deux fois, trois
fois, quatre fois, cin fois pour être
vraiment aller au fond des choses et
puis le côté essayée, je regarde le
monde tel qu'il pas de vrai mais tel
qu'il pourrait être et je pose la
question pourquoi
pas et là c'est très drôle parce que bah
c'est la première fois donc je fais ça à
peu près depuis une trentaine d'années
et c'est la première fois
que les modèles économiques des trois
grandes puissances la Chine, l'Europe et
les US, les trois modèles économiques
pètent en même temps, ce que j'ai jamais
vu. Historiquement, j'ai vu un modèle
peut-être péter, mais les trois à la
fois, j'ai jamais vu. Donc, il y a des
gens qui sont très déprimés en disant
"Mais c'est la fin du monde et moi je
suis très excité parce que c'est le côté
pourquoi pas ? Je sens qu'il va falloir
reconstruire un nouveau monde." Donc
c'est ça qui c'est ça côté investisseur,
saisir les opportunités et puis le côté
essayiste en disant pourquoi pas. Alors,
j'ai pas j'ai pas compris le côté euh
négrier. Euh c'est c'est c'était la la
blague. Ah ben c'est-à-dire que non,
mais c'est qu'à Paris le terme
d'investisseur, il y a pas pire. Euh
c'est un métier où on ne travaille pas,
on fait travailler les autres, on les
exploite, on empêche des dividendes sans
rien faire et cetera. OK. Vous pesez
combien ? Euh 55 kg. Non, en million. Ah
55 kg. 55 millions ? Non, 55 kg. C'est
votre fond, il représente combien ? Le
Alors, j'ai pas de fond. J'investis avec
des copains. On Ça représente quel
volume ? Euh on dit pas parce que on est
c'est sont des petits volumes. C'est pas
J'ai eu j'ai à des moments j'ai géré
beaucoup d'argent quand j'ai quand
j'étais quand je suis parti d'un gros
investisseur américain. Il y a je gérais
6 milliards de dollars à l'époque. Ce
qui est à l'époque c'était raisonnable.
C'était en c'était en 2005 donc 6
milliards à l'époque. Oui, c'était pas
mal. C'était correct.
Voilà. Non non mais je suis pas gros
encore une fois je suis 55 kg et c'est
plus une question de cervelle que de
vous dans ce métier ce qui exordire
c'est que vous avez des gens qui gèrent
énormément d'argent et qui sont très
mauvais puis a des gens qui gèrent très
peu d'argent mais qui sont très bons.
Ouais puis on se rappelle tous de
l'espoir c'est que vous savez le
meilleur c'est Waren Buffet quand vous
regardez sa fortune aujourd'hui 95 % de
sa fortune
vient de ce qu'il a gagné après 65 ans.
Donc j'ai pas encore 65 ans. Je me dis
encore on se rappelle tous de Madofre.
On va aujourd'hui parler guerre
économique, on va
parler perspective pour l'Europe, on va
parler politique, on va parler
innovation, on va
parler, on va dire ceux qui sont censés
anticiper un budget, des recettes, une
balance commerciale et gens passer des
meilleurs. On commence déjà par le titre
de votre bouquin qui s'appelle bienvenue
en guerre, en économie de guerre,
pardon. Qui dit économie de guerre ?
dit renseignement. Qui dit renseignement
dit prospective qui dit renseignement
prospective dit analyse. Comment vous en
ayant un pied du côté de l'Asie, en
ayant une expérience lonienne dans la
finance, comment vous évaluez la
situation de la France et de l'Europe ?
pour vous ça va, il y a des
opportunités, on va s'en sortir ou on
est à deux doigts de se faire manger
jusqu'à l'os. Alors les les deux vont
général, faut d'abord définir l'économie
de guerre. Donc l'économie de guerre euh
c'est pas la guerre premièrement. Et
deuxièmement, contrairement à ce que
raconte le président de la République,
c'est pas l'économie de défense. Donc là
où il y a à mon avis une
mécompréhension, c'est que le président
de la République nous dit euh on va
passer le budget de la défense de 2 à 3
% et euh vous inquiétez pas, en gros
français, vous n'avez rien à faire. Le
premier ministre dit le modèle social
français ne sera pas
affecté. C'est totalement faux.
L'économie de guerre, ça se définit par
opposition à l'économie de paix.
L'économie de paix, c'est ce que j'ai
connu. On a oublié parce qu'on est dans
le très court terme. Quel âge vous avez
? Alors, mentalement, je vais vous
expliquer que j'ai 3 ans d'âge mental
parce que en 2022, pour moi, le monde a
totalement changé et dès que j'ai plus
de 3 ans,
je fais des conneries et je perds de
l'argent parce que j'ai des
raisonnements d'hier qui ne
s'appliquitent plus. Et puis
biologiquement, ben je me souviens plus
exactement quand je suis né parce que
euh j'avais pas pleine conscience. Donc
on va dire ça fait ça fait un
demi-siècle, voyez, à peu près. Et donc
économique guerre dit guerre économique.
Alors oui, mais surtout il faut bien
comprendre l'économie de paix que j'ai
connu pendant 30 ans, j'ai eu une chance
incroyable. Ma génération a une chance
incroyable parce qu'on a commencé à
travailler après 1989. On a eu un cycle
de 30 ans. Les cycles, l'économie, c'est
30 ans. C'est les cycles de Condratièv,
c'est en gros une génération. Et de 1989
à 2020, on a été en économie de paix au
sens où l'économie a été tirée par la
demande, par un client. Donc, j'ai
essayé de trouver des sociétés qui
créaient un service ou un produit pour
lequel il y avait une valeur ajoutée qui
était perçue par le client. L'économie
de guerre, c'est exactement l'inverse.
Vous n'êtes pas tiré par la demande et
le consommateur, vous êtes tiré par
l'offre et plus particulièrement le
goulot d'étranglement à l'offre. parce
qu'en fait les condiens, il est
impossible de produire. Donc ma
grand-mère de 1940 à 1944 est en
économie de guerre. Elle va chez Beurre
au
fromage et elle veut du Rockfort mais il
y a que du Topinambourg. Donc le
producteur de Rockfort, il fait férite
parce que c'est impossible de faire du
Rockfort parce que pour faire du
Rockfort, il faut tout un tas de trucs
très très compliqués. Et par contre le
producteur de Topinambourg dont tout le
monde se foutait en 1939 parce que
personne n'en voulait bah comme du
Topinambourg vous pouvez en faire autant
que voulez il fait fortune. Et donc ce
que j'ai vu, la raison pour laquelle je
suis en compte c'est que ce changement
donc il y a un énorme pour investisseur
en tant qu'investisseur il y a un énorme
transfert de valeur du
consommateur à la
production et la Chine l'a compris bien
avant les autres. on pourra y revenir.
Donc la Chine a 10 ans d'avance sur
nous. On va pas y revenir, on va on va
le traiter tout de suite. On y va tout
de suite. Donc la Chine a compris ça.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la Chine a décidé
de reprendre l'hégémonie mondiale. La
Chine a décidé de se venger des 100
années de honte. La Chine a compris ça
parce que elle a compris que les
États-Unis étaient devenu une puissance
impérialiste, schizophrène et mythomane.
La Chine a compris ça. Pourquoi ? Alors,
elle l'a compris euh à mon sens par un
homme qui s'appelle Sjing qui est arrivé
au pouvoir en
2012, à une époque où euh les États-Unis
se remettaient à peine de commenceraient
à se remettre de la crise du subprime,
enfin tout l'Occident, la crise du
subrime de 2008 et la Chine était peu
endettée. Donc la Chine avait avait une
force de frappe financière comparée à
l'Occident. Et il y a eu un grand débat
à l'époque en Chine, dont on a pas parlé
en Europe parce que très peu de gens
s'intéressaient à la Chine, entre cet
argent, est-ce qu'on l'investit dans une
infrastructure sociale pour développer
le marché intérieur ou est-ce qu'on
l'utilise pour construire ce que vous
appelez alors on peut dire une puissance
chinoise, une hégémonie chinoise ? Et à
l'époque, c'était plus déjà le concept
d'autosuffisant. C'est c'est là que CHi
est arrivé en 2013 avec le concept des
nouvelles routes de la soie et qui a été
en fait l'idée derrière c'est tel que je
le comprends cétait en fait le vrai la
véritable idée c'était d'assurer la
Chine est jamais hégémonique n'est
jamais sortie de chez elle n'a jamais
fait la guerre voà elle sort un peu de
chez elle avec la mer de Chine. Non mais
l'idée ça a été d'assurer le sourcing.
Donc je suis allé à l'étranger pour
trouver le sourcing des choses dont
j'avais besoin pour mon économie
intérieure. Vous avez lu la guerre hors
limite ? Oui, c'est la Bible, ça c'est
1999. Et alors ça, on y reviendra un peu
plus tard parce que c'est la guerre
hybride. C'est pour mais juste pour que
vous compreniez la séquence. En 2015,
Chi est arrivé en ayant suffisamment
confiance pour arriver avec un made in
China 2025 qui a été très critiqué après
à l'intérieur de la Chine en disant tu
es sorti beaucoup trop tôt du bois. Et
l'idée c'est qu'il a dit il y a 10
industries qui sont absolument
stratégiques et pour lesquelles la Chine
sera numéro 1 en 2025. il voulait
galvaniser sa population. Et le vrai
tournant qu'on a pas compris ici, c'est
2017.
Parce qu'en 2017, vous avez une société
qui s'appelle Broadcom, société chinoise
qui était basée à Singapour qui fait une
OPA sur une société américaine qui
s'appelle Qualcom et qui est une société
qui fait de l'IP, donc du de
l'intelligence des de l'intelligence
pour toute la tech y compris les
semi-conducteurs. Mais à l'époque Donald
Trump, il y en avait pour 120 milliards
de dollars. Et Donald Trump dirigeait
les États-Unis à l'époque, c'était Trump
1.0 zéro et Trump a dit il fallait
l'autorisation américaine pour acheter
la société et Trump a dit "Mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? C'est pas
possible. Qu'est-ce que c'est que des
Chinois qu'on 12 milliard ? Ça n'existe
pas." Trump a arrêté le pas faut bien
comprendre parce que c'est c'est
vraiment le tournant et il a dit "Bon
un, les Chinois n'auront jamais la
technologie américaine", mais deux, il a
dit à CD mais comment as a-t-on laissé
des Chinois accumuler 120 milliards de
dollars de market de capitalisation pour
ça ? Ça n'existe pas. Il y a que les
États-Unis qui ont 120 milliards et donc
dites-moi les autres qui d'autres
Chinois nous menace ? Et à l'époque les
numéro c'était HW et Z parce que il
dominait l'infrastructure télécom. Il y
avait que qui savaient faire de la 5G
alors que les US étaient nulle part
notamment Motorola qui était au tapis.
Et donc le président Trump a dit comment
on peut les stopper ? On a dit ils ont
besoin de semi-conducteurs américains et
du jour au lendemain Trump a tout coupé.
Quelle était ma question ? et de on y
vient. Oui, c'est Non, mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis venu vous
voir, c'est que les réponses soit je les
fais en 30 secondes et à ce moment-là je
vais à télévision, soit je vais chez
Serveriew, ça dure très longtemps. Mais
on peut pas, si vous voulez, on peut pas
comprendre une rupture de 30 ans en 30
secondes. Il faut que vous compreniez la
genèse. Et donc Trump a dit "Je coupe."
Alors, il se trouve que HW avait des
stocks mais ZTE n'avait pas de stock et
donc ZTE a fait fight en un jour. Il y
avait plus de 50000 emplois. Et donc Shi
a été obligé de prendre son téléphone et
d'appeler Trump en disant "Donne-moi 3
mois de stock pour que ZTE survive." Ce
que les États-Unis ont fait et le
président Chie a dit à son équipe,
"C'est la dernière fois, c'est la c'est
là, on est de retour à 842. C'est la
dernière fois que la Chine s'humilie à
appeler les Américains pour demander
quoi que ce soit." Et donc là où je vous
dis que c'est un tournant, là où c'est
vous me demandez pourquoi la Chine a
compris les comidères, c'est que c'est
en 2017 que Shi a dit nous devons
poursuivre
l'autosuffisance et
donc la production chinoise doit se
faire sans les États-Unis. La raison
pour laquelle
aujourd'hui et on va y venir la raison
pour laquelle la Chine je pense dans ce
conflit qui s'en vénim avec les
États-Unis est en avance c'est que elle
s'y prépare depuis 2017. On est en 2025
donc ça fait 8 ans que la Chine s'est
prépare. Le Covid a accéléré parce que
vous vous avez été enfermé chez vous à
ne rien faire et à commander en
e-commerce des choses à dire chinois qui
ont été enfermé à l'usine 7 jours sur 7
24. Donc la part de marché chinoise du
manufacturing est passé mondial pendant
le Covid est passé de 30 à 35 %. On
était enfermé mais on consomme français.
Non, vous étiez vous étiez sur internet
en train de d'acheter des trucs que la
France ne pouvait pas produire puisque
toutes nos usines étaient fermées. Et
madame Non, mais madame Sky a dit tiens,
on va changer je sais pas quoi, on va
acheter une nouvelle bière, on va on va
changer la cuisine tout ça, on va
acheter les casseroles, tout ça. Non
non, on on était à Oh si on seit des
petites côtes de port de noir de bigore.
Et oui mais les côtes de porc vous les
fait cuire dans une poêle que vous avez
commandé parce que madame une poêle qui
a été faite à tournue. Alors parfait
parce que là vous avez acheté un truc
mais tout le monde n'est pas Madame Sky.
Il y a d'autres ménagères pas madame Sky
qui fait à manger à la maison. Ah !
Alors, si c'est vous, c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'elle vient de tournue. Bravo.
Mais il se trouve qu'il y a euh 400
millions d'Européens et 350 millions
d'Américains qui eux ont dit "On va
commander." Donc la Chine est passée de
30 à 35 %, objectif 45 % en 2030. Mais
les moyennes sont toujours trompeuses,
vous le savez. et que ce qui est
important, c'est que quand vous faites
35 %, ce que les États-Unis vont
découvrir aujourd'hui, c'est que quand
vous faites 35 % du manufacturing
mondial, c'estàd que vous êtes présent
dans toutes les chaînes de valeur et que
quand vous êtes usé, ça fait 8 ans que
vous bossez sur le
sujet, vous avez identifié des petits
goulets d'étranglement qui valent pas
cher du tout. Pour synthétiser votre
réponse, on peut se passer des
États-Unis, mais on peut pas se passer
de la Chine. Alors, on est, c'est pour
ça que j'ai vu à Hong Kong, c'est que le
combat, il est américain chinois. Il
s'est très bien passé jusqu'il y a à mon
sens 10 jours. S'est très bien passé
jusqu'en 2022 parce que c'était
Kissinger qui avait dit euh vous êtes
obligé de vous entendre parce que vous
faites 600 milliards de business
ensemble. Donc vous êtes obligé de vous
entendre. C'est un piège de tu c'est le
premier piège de tucidit. Donc piège de
tucidit, c'est la le numéro 2 qui
rivalise le numéro 1. Et c'est la
première fois qu'ils font c'est pas qui
avait zéro business avec les États-Unis.
Donc la théorie, la doctrine de
Kissinger, c'était vous êtes obligé
d'entendre. Donc on définit les ligne
rouges. C'est le 7 octobre 2022, ce que
j'ai appelé le pharbore dans mon livre.
Le donc le 7 octobre en Chine, c'est
absolument pas 2023, on s'en fout
complètement. Donc ici, il y a que ça
qui compte. Et à l'inverse, le 7 octobre
2022 à Paris, personne n'a entendu
parler. Pour nous à Hong Kong, c'est
crucial. C'est le jour où les
États-Unis, 10 jours avant le 20e
congrès où chi fait son coup d'état, les
États-Unis disent "On vous coupe la
haute technologie définie par
semi-conducteur, intelligence
artificielle
et quantum computing." Donc on peut
appeler ça le la puissance de calcul. Et
avec ça, les États-Unis disent "On est
bon parce qu'on domine le 21e siècle."
On a compris seulement 2 mois plus tard,
la Chine n'a pas réagi à l'époque. Ça
qui été extraordinaire parce que elle a
pas compris le geste des États-Unis.
C'est seulement 2 mois plus tard que
Chat GPT est arrivé que Open Air est
arrivé dit "J'ai trouvé un truc de
malade qui s'appelle Jen ai et qui va
changer la manière dont
l'information circule." Ils ont balancé
ça gratos sur internet et le cours des
autres se sont c'est s c'est cassé la
bouette. La Chine a répondu en disant la
Chine qui était absolument pas au
courant encore. A dit à Baidou qui a le
l'équivalent si vous voulez de du Google
chinois a dit "Vous devez me faire un
truc."
Et donc Baidou a organisé une conférence
d'investisseur au mois de mars 2023. Non
mais on a la même chose le cours de
Baidou. Donc il y avait un il y avait
Ernie qu'on a interrogé qui racontait
n'importe quoi. Donc le cours de Baidou
a fait moins 10 % dans la journée en
disant les Chinas sont nulle part. Donc
les Américains ont bombé le torse en
disant vous voyez que en fait la Chine
ira nulle part.
J'avance, je fais puisque le temps
tourne, j'avance très vite et on se
retrouve en 2024 avec euh début 2025 psy
qui arrivent et qui dit "Moi, je vous
fais le même truc que les Américains à
peu près pour les Américains. C'est 500
milliards de dollars." C'est ce que
Trump a annoncé avec Sovban qui est Open
et dans son bureau. Moi, je vous le fais
pour 5 millions dans une cave. Dans une
cave. Donc, les États-Unis ont dit
"Attends, ça me paraît quand même pas
tout à fait réel. Euh ce type fund
manager qui a un macro edge fund qui
gagne qui a 20 milliards sousgestions,
qui gagne 200 millions qui les remet
dans des on y comprend rien, on va
creuser. Et là vous apercevez que
Singapour donc des gens très très bien
Singapour c'est gens que tout le monde
respecte fait 20 % du chiffre d'affaires
de Nvidia. Donc le chiffre d'affaires de
Nvidia, c'est 100 milliards de dollars.
Donc ça fait quand même 20 milliards de
dollars US hein, c'est pas rien. Et que
sur ces 20 % des plus Nvidia, Singapour
maximum, comme ils sont juste 6 7
millions de personnes euh en utilise 1
%. Donc il y a 19 % qui se baladent un
peu partout dans le monde. Alors les
sacaporiens disent ne vous inquiétez
pas, on les on les revend aux
occidentaux, ça va chez TSMC qui
fabrique pour l'Occident. Et puis on
découvre qu'en
Malaisie, ben il y a des data center que
vous pouvez louer. Alors c'est un peu
comme chez vous, vous pouvez louer un
appartement à Paris, vous pouvez louer
meublé ou non meublé. Bah vous pouvez
louer des data center en Malaisie
meublés avec des puces Nvidia de très
haute qualité qui appartiennent au
projet équiti américain. Donc le loyer
est juste 10 10000 fois ce que vous
devriez payer normalement et ça c'est
loué à des sociétés chinoises qui en
profitent pour faire tourner leur
machine et ça revient en Chine. Donc les
républicains arrivent et
disent la technique toute la stratégie
démocrate que la guerre est
technologique et que il suffit de couper
la
tech parce que l'embargo sur la tech
américaine c'est comme l'embargo sur le
pétrole russe. Il y a toujours c'est
pour eux ça passe toujours et la Chine
est en train de nous avoir. Et donc
c'est pour ça que dans cette rivalité
américaine, il y a une cassure totale.
Et donc les Américains sont arrivés,
c'est Scott Bessent, le secrétaire du
trésor qui est arrivé et qui a dit "Bon
bah euh le seul moyen, c'est ce qu'on a
fait au Japon en 1985." C'est-à-dire que
c'est la guerre monétaire. La guerre
monétaire dans alors moi je fais pas du
tout de militaire mais la guerre
monétaire chez moi c'est le nucléaire.
C'est c'est le Napal. Vous mettez vous
détruisez une monnaie, vous détruisez
toute l'activité d'un pays. Et donc à
l'époque en 1985, juste pour nos
auditeurs, les États-Unis avaient forcé
le Japon de réévaluer leur monnaie de 40
% de manière à ce que l'économie
japonaise ne soit plus compétitive. Et
donc là tout le jeu de Scott Ben c'est
un article dans Economist du mois
d'octobre qu'il faut absolument que vous
lisiez si vous l'avez pas lu, qui a dit
"Nous allons escalate before
decalating." Donc on va escalader avant
de d'escalader et on va arriver et ce
qu'on va faire c'est que on va utiliser
un truc qu'on a pas utilisé depuis 1930
qui s'appelle les tarifs. les tarifs
doués les et ça historiquement ça a été
utilisé pour si monsieur Sky vous vous
comportez très très mal vous par exemple
vous vendez des trucs que vous
subventionnez ben j'ai un tarif je vais
à l'OMC je dis je dois taxer les
produits qui viennent de chez Skyland
parce que il subventionnent et là les
États-Unis ont invé un nouveau un
nouveau modèle qui a de dire ça va être
en fait un moyen de lever de l'argent
pour les États-Unis de financer leurs
déficit, de financer leur budget. Alors,
c'est là où il faut qu'on viienne, je
comprends le le fait que vous essayez
d'élargir le prisme de lecture pour
expliquer la sit la situation française
européenne. On peut pas comprendre si
euh vous inquiétez pas, notre communauté
comprend. Donc votre point de vue, on
reviendra sur la Chine, on reviendra sur
les États-Unis, on reviendra sur cette
guerre commerciale, on reviendra en
détail sur la guerre économique.
D'ailleurs, vous connaissez le proverbe
en guerre économique, un chômeur coûte
plus cher qu'un
mort. Donc, revenons à la France. Ouais.
Revenons. Vous savez pourquoi un chômeur
coûte plus cher qu'un mort. Quand vous
créez des chômeurs dans l'économie que
vous attaquez,
l'État est obligé de mettre au pot. Oui.
Donc il accélère sa chute, ses déficits.
Oui. Bon, revenons à la France. Revenons
à pe faire ça aussi avec le retraité. On
y reviendra.
La France, l'Europe. Alors, OK. Vous
voulez qu'on parte par on part de la fin
? Il y a aucun problème. Comme ça, on
part on part de ce qui nous intéresse en
priorité. He alors on a un pillage sans
précédent parce que la guerre d'Ukraine,
oui, à Hong Kong, on ne m'a jamais
mentionné la guerre d'Ukraine. Personne
ne me parle de la guerre d'Ukraine. Vous
êtes pas dans les bons cercles peut-être
? Non, c'est pas ça, mais c'est que
c'est pas le c'est un épiphénomène. Le
vrai combat, il est entre la Chine et
les États-Unis. Donc derrière l'URSS, il
y a enfin pardon la Russie, il y a la
Chine. Et derrière l'Europe, il y a
l'Ukraine, il y a les États-Unis. Et
l'idée c'est de per l'Europe. C'est ce
que j'appelle la yéisation de l'Europe.
C'estàd que quand l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite se font quand deux grandes
puissances se tapent dessus, elle ne se
tape pas chez elle. Elle se tape
toujours dans un géographie tierce. La
géographie tierce. Exactement. proxy
donc c'est aujourd'hui l'Europe donc les
la Chine
pille la Russie 2 % du PNB mondial en
achetant du pétrole russe seulement en
ARMB chinois donc vous savez qu'il y a
un contrôle d'échange donc Poutine est
obligé d'acheter des importations
chinoises et les Chinois de manière
assez rusée leur envoient les trucs qui
ne pourraient vendre nul part ailleurs.
Donc défaut des puces électroniques 40
%. Euh vous avez peut-être vu qu'il y a
un mois les importations de camions
chinois en Russie ont été stoppées parce
que les ne respectaiit aucune consigne
sécurité. Il y avait pas de frein. Vous
savez qu'il y a 800000 voitures
chinoises qui vont réussir qui sont des
poubelles. Ça rien à voir avec les
voitures électriques avec lesquelles il
nous envoyir. Donc bravo, la Chine vous
pillez 2 % du PNB. Et ce dont on ne se
rend pas compte ici, c'est que nous nous
Europe, on est 20 % du PNB mondial et
qu'on se fait piller par les États-Unis
sans précédent par un quadruple
transfert de valeur qui est bah d'abord
l'énergie puisqu'on va aller acheter du
ce qu'on appelle le gaz naturel liquéfié
5 à 10 fois ce qu'on payait à Poutine.
Vous avez bien vu que la guerre
d'Ukraine, nous avons so entre 2 ti et
75 % des armes que nous avons utilisé
viennent des États-Unis, donc les acheté
aux États-Unis.
Euh Jen et euh donc tous les logiciels,
vous voyez bien que l'ardoise comme ces
gens mettent 300 milliards de
d'investissement naturellement ils vont
nous le facturer à un prix démentiel. Et
puis sur le gâteau sous Biden, il y
avait le programme IRA qui était un
programme de désindustrialisation de
l'Europe puisque vous aviez des
subventions de manière à investir aux
États-Unis, y compris pour aspirer nos
talents. Absolument, c'est ça prè Trump.
Mais là ça change avec Trump. Et je
reviens à mon histoire de tarif, c'est
que je pense moi personnellement cette
histoire de tarif n'a aucun sens. Donc
on est quand même dans le royaume. Faut
pas dire que ça a aucun sens. Faut dire
que vous ne comprenez pas. Si, je
comprends. Je Pourquoi ça n'a pas de
sens ? Alors ça n'a pas de sens parce
que me dire que les Cambodgiens et les
Vietnamiens depuis 50 ans se sont
enrichis de manière indu sur le pauvre
consommateur américain, ça n'a aucun
sens. D'accord. La capitalisation
boursière des États-Unis représente 70 %
de la capitalisation boursière mondiale.
Donc que des gens qui que 34 % de la
population qui s'est accaparé 70 % de la
valeur mondiale hurle en disant je me
fais pied par le reste du monde. Ça n'a
aucun sens. Quand madame Van Derleyenne
propose aux États-Unis zéro droit de
douane bilatéral et que les États-Unis
disent je ne suis pas intéressé, ça veut
dire que les tarifs n'ont aucun sens.
Donc ça c'est ce que j'adore. C'est là
où mon métier est fantastique, c'est que
je n'ai jamais été aussi heureux d'être
un investisseur parce que plus on est
dans le royaume des fake news, plus j'ai
une justification pour mon métier. Donc
je dis si c'est pas ça, qu'est-ce que
c'est ? Un réflexe de Lawrence.
Alors en l'occurrence c'est Ferguson que
je regarde, c'est Nil Ferguson qui est
un historien britannique et qui a de
manière très modeste inventé la loi de
Ferguson et qui dit que sur le plan
géopolitique, si vous voulez connaître
le poids d'un pays, vous comparez ses
dépenses militaires aux intérêts qui
paye sur sa dette souveraine et que le
jour où par exemple Royaume-Unire 1945,
vous payez plus d'intérêt
sur votre dette, vous remboursez pas la
dette, juste les intérêts que en budget
militaire, vous faites plus de tout peur
aux autres parce que les autres disent
il a pas les moyens de ses ambitions. Je
peux vous offrir un autre signal
précurseur qui va dans votre sens ? Je
suis sûr que vous le connaissez déjà.
Alors si vous me dites Piketti, non
parce que Petti c'est à cause de lui qui
avec les ann qui racontent de dire il y
a pas de limite à la dette publique.
C'est pour ça qu'on est pas de
dénigrement. Pardon, je vous ai
d'accord pour d'autres c'est pas des
zeries, pas de dénigrement ici. Très
bien. Pour revenir sur votre indice
précurseur pour détecter le pouvoir
d'une puissance, est-ce que vous avez
essayé de calculer les intérêts de la
dette française journalier en baril de
pétrole et de la et de les comparer à
notre consommation journalière de baril
de pétrole ? Alors là, vous si vous êtes
très très en avance sur bois, donc
allez-y. On consomme un peu plus d'un
million de barils par jour en France.
Ouais. Et les intérêts de notre dette
représentent 2 millions de barils.
Ouai, c'est bien. C'est ce qu'on appelle
économie de guerre, la dépendance. Donc
c'est tout tout le boulot qu'il faut
qu'on fasse, c'est de comprendre les
nouvelles dépendances qu'on n pas
réalisé. Mais je reviens aux États-Unis
quand même pour finir. Aujourd'hui, les
deux courbes, elles sont à 3 % du PNB.
Les militaires dépensent 3 % du PNB
américain et ils vous disent la guerre
froide, on était à 5 et on n pas fait le
pivot. Hillary Clinton en 2011 a fait un
discours fois absolument qu'on pivote
vers l'Asie. On est plus de 10 ans plus
tard, on n pas fait le pivot. Donc on a
10 à 15 ans de sous-investissement en
Asie. Donc le 3, faut absolument qu'il
monte à 5. Le 3 % d'intérêt sur la
dette, c'est parce que vous avez 120 %
de dette sur PNB qui paye des intérêts
historiques de 2,5 %. Mais aujourd'hui,
les taux américains, ils sont à 4 et
demi. Et donc si vous refinancez la
dette américaine, par exemple, vous avez
6 trillions à refinancer. 6 trillions,
enfin 6000 milliards, il y a pas de
trillons en français. 6000 milliards de
dollars cette année, vous avez 4000
milliards. Donc vous avez 10000
milliards, c'est 1/3 du PNB américain
que vous avez
refinancer en 2 ans. Si vous mettez 5 %
là-dessus, vous êtes à 6 % du PNB en
intérêt. Vous êtes à deux fois le budget
militaire. Et donc les militaires disent
ça c'est pas possible. Le 3 qui monte à
5, c'est pour nous, c'est pas pour des
rentiers qui achètent de la dette
américaine. Et donc tout le problème que
nous avons, c'est que il faut
aujourd'hui dans notre jargon, on dit
délivrer il faut
désendetter
l'Amérique et
que quand la Chine a sauvé le monde en
2008, il y a une grande crise financière
et c'est la Chine qui a sauvé le monde
avec un plan de stimulus très important.
En mars 2020, quand vous étiez en train
de faire vos côtes de veau dans votre
poil
TFAL, si les tournu tournu pardon, si
les Américains n'avaient pas mis 12000
milliards de dollars sur la table,
c'estàd 35 % de PNB, on ne serait plus
là. Et donc les Américains disent à
raison, c'est le reste de la planète qui
doit rembourser.
Et donc juste pour que vous mettiez un
peu les choses en perspective, quand Ben
Laden a fait sauter les tours en
2001, le plan stimulus pour relancer
l'économie américaine, c'est 3 % du PNB
américain. En 2008, quand les subprime
pet, c'est 12 % du PNB américain. En
2020, quand le Covid fait péter
l'économie mondiale, c'est 35 % du PNB
américain. Et donc les Américains
aujourd'hui viennent et nous disent
"Désolé mais vous le reste du monde." Il
sauf que moi Trump, il est tort de
question que mes copains milliardaires
payent des impôts. Donc on va faire
payer les étrangers, tous les
exportateurs vers les États-Unis et on
va faire payer les pauvres parce que ce
sont les pauvres qui achètent les
produits importés. Et donc c'est ça le
problème que nous avons à résoudre. Le
problème que nous avons résoudre, c'est
absolument pas une histoire de tarif
dont on vous parle depuis un mois et
demi qui n'est absolument pas le sujet
puisquison leur a proposé zéro et qui
disent on n'est pas intéressé. Et par
contre ce qu'il faut et donc j'ai écrit
une tribune dans l'opinion qui est un
journal que je vous recommande en disant
il faut un Breton Wood parce que ce qui
nous arrive aujourd'hui c'est c'est
arrivé en 194 c'est en fait on a on a un
endettement mondial qui est un
endettement de sortie de guerre de 1944
alors qu'en fait on entre
potentiellement dans des conflits et
donc le seul moyen de le résoudre c'est
d'avoir un bretonut comme en 1944 où à
l'époque on s'est mis d'accord sur le
fait que les taux américains resteraient
jusqu'en 1951 à 2 %, il y aurait de
l'inflation de 5 6 % donc les épargnants
qui sont les rentiers perdraient 3 4 %
par an parce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
des taux réels négatifs et que ça
permettrait à tous les entrepreneurs de
redémarrer. Et donc tant qu'on n pas ce
Breton Wood
aujourd'hui et ben on va aller dans le
mur et les la seule personne qui peut
appeler le
Benonwood c'est l'Europe. Et le problème
qu'on a, c'est que euh on va pas faire
de dénigrement, mais malheureusement euh
donc pour ça, il faut la Banque centrale
européenne et malheureusement nous
n'avons pas le leadership à la tête de
la Banque centrale européenne pour
convoquer un Breton Wood et dire aux
Chinois et aux Américains, les
Américains vous consommez beaucoup trop,
les Chinois vous épargnez beaucoup trop.
Donc c'est évident qu'on peut combiner
les deux et trouver une solution. Mais
aujourd'hui, Trump dit je préfère mon
plan c'est que les États-Unis payent
zéro et que l'étranger paye 100 %. Et
c'est pour ça qu'on est pas d'accord et
que là ça ne va pas marcher. OK. La
France
alors la France qui est 33 minutes quand
même pour faire le tour de l'échien.
Oui. Alors c'est pour ça j'ai jamais
travaillé en France moi. C'est ça que
j'ai un petit problème. C'est que jamais
vos impôts en France ? Je paye des
impôts en France bien sûr parce que vous
n'avez pas besoin de travailler en
France pour payer des impôts. Ça en
France ça de toute façon. carte de la
sécurité sociale. Alors, j'ai non, j'ai
mais j'ai un une carte des euh je sais
pas quoi, des non des Français
d'étranger. J'ai une assurance des
Français de l'étranger. Vous payz
combien de mémoire ? Écoutez, je sais
pas, je crois que c'est 1000 € par an
pour être rassuré. Quand je suis en
France, s'il m'arrive un truc, quand je
suis en France, j'y vais et je vais à
l'hôpital et mais j'ai pas de carte
vite. J'ai jamais eu de carte vitale.
Euh le
par chinois, non. Euh c'est c'est 12000
he pour pas dire de conneries. Donc les
12000 heures, je les ai passé à parler à
des gens qui connaissaient la Chine. Euh
pour revenir à votre question, la
France, quand je dis qu'il y a une crise
monétaire et qu'il y a une crise de la
dette américaine parce qu'il y a 120 %
de PNB de dettes sur PNB aux États-Unis.
Bon ben s'il y a une
crise aux
États-Unis et que nous avons en gros le
même endettement des États-Unis mais on
ne trouve pas Nvidia qui vaut 3
trillions de dollars de market cap.
intuitivement, on a peut-être un petit
problème. Alors, prenons encore
l'Europe, une perspective un peu
historique. L'Europe, ça pète tous les
10 ans. Tous les 10 ans, vous avez un
pays qui pète. La Suède en 1990 qui
aujourd'hui est le meilleur pays qui est
notre modèle à suivre, on y reviendra.
2000 des fonds souverains 2000 non.
Fonds privés. et
Valenberg 2000 l'Allemagne 2010 la Grèce
2020 personne France non parce que vous
avez le Covid on arrose donc en fait on
est les rois de la piste il y aura plus
de d'ê souveraines et il y a un truc qui
est très perverse si vous parlez à des
Grecs il y a un truc qui est très très
pervers avec les crises
souveraines c'est qu'en fait la crise
souveraine ne vient pas du pays qui
subit la crise c'est celui qui détient
la dette et non c'est l'environnement
c'est-à-dire que vous parlez aux Grecs,
les Grecs, ils vous disent "Mais
pourquoi ça a pété en 2010 ?" Encore en
2010, je faisais exactement ce que je
faisais en 2000 en 2005. Et si se trouve
que en 2010, il y a une crise de l'euro
et qu'on a dit "Bah, désolé les Grecs,
mais vos chiffres dont on sait qu'ils
sont complètement faux depuis 10 ans,
maintenant on dit qu'ils sont faux et on
vous rentre dedans." Et aujourd'hui en
Europe, on a un tremblement de terre qui
a
l'Allemagne. Qui est l'Allemagne ? Parce
que aujourd'hui notre dette souveraine
c'est nous français c'est 300 milliards
qu'il faut qu'on aille chercher sur les
marchés tous les ans. C'est pas 365. Non
c'est
300 nous déficit plus refinancement de
la dette existence c'est
300. Et pourquoi pourquoi les gens nous
donnent 300 ? Euh c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont extrêmement impressionnés par la
gestion de Bruno Lemire et de François
Berou. C'est tout simplement que quand
vous êtes un investisseur, quand vous
êtes un assureur européen et que vous
êtes obligé d'avoir des actifs en euros,
vousz de la dette, ben il y a pas de
dette allemande parce que les Allemands,
vous avez pas de déficit. Les Italiens,
ils achètent tous leur dette eux-mêmes,
elle est uniquement domestique et les
Espagnols, le marché est trop petit.
Donc la seule dette que vous avez pu
acheter qui est suffisamment liquide,
c'est
la c'est que
l'Allemagne, monsieur le nouveau
chancelier Frédéric Mertz a dit "Moi, je
suis la Chine de 2008, je suis le seul
pays à pas être endetté
aujourd'hui. Les US sont complètement
surendettés. La Chine est totalement
surendettée. L'Europe est surendetté. Il
y a que moi qui a 60 % de dette sur PNB
au lieu de 120. Donc je lance un plan
d'investissement de 1000 milliards
d'euros. Et donc je vais lancer l'an
prochain, je sais je connais pas le
chiffre, on verra mais ça pourrait être
de l'ordre de 300 milliards
d'euros. Et donc nos assureurs européens
qui cette année nous achètent 300
milliards, l'an prochain, ils ont donné
allemande. Il y a que 70 points de base,
enfin 0.7 % de différence d'intérêt.
Donc vous dites pour juste 0.7 % qui je
préfère
forcément. Bah voilà. Bah voilà. Ben
non, les Allemands et donc naturellement
tout le monde va acheter de la dette
allemande en disant ces types sont
sérieux, ils sont sous-endettés et donc
je serai remboursé. On voit s'agiter
avec le fait de diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires en France de s'agiter pas
du tout, on ne fait absolument rien.
Non, c'est pour ça qu'on a on dit qu'il
s'agitait. C'est pour ça que et je suis
pas dans le moi je fais pas du tout de
politique mais vu de l'extérieur c'est
pour ça qu'on a changé un secrétaire
général de l'Élysée. Il y en a un
nouveau qui est le spécialiste des
crises souveraines puisque c'est lui qui
a traité au nom de la France la crise de
l'euro en 2010. Vous voyez, c'est les
c'est les petits enfin il va soit que si
je suis au courant, je suis désolé,
c'est pas un scoop pour nos auditeurs.
Euh ce qu'on ne sait pas, c'est le
timing. Est-ce que ça va être 2026 que
ça va être 2027 ? Et donc, vous avez
deux solutions. Euh bah soit ça pète et
vous avez le FMI, donc c'est la Grèce en
2010, soit il y a un deal qui est fait
avec les Allemands à travers la
BCE. Et à mon sens, les Allemands qui
sont des gens extrêmement sympathiques,
vous savez qu'il y a un couple
franco-allemand.
Il y a un couple franco-allemand à
Paris. Moi, j'ai vécu 2 ans, j'ai
travaillé 2 ans à Berlin. Je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de couple
franco-allemands. Ça n'existe qu'à
Paris. Donc, il y a zéro coup
francoallemand. Et je ne vois pas les
Allemands actuellement qui ont quand
même des problèmes à résoudre dire "Je
finance la France sans aucun problème."
Donc, quoi qu'il arrive, notre modèle
est cassé et nous devons le
reconstruire. Est-ce que vous avez
essayé de creuser les pistes guerre
économique ? Est-ce que vous avez essayé
de réfléchir sur comment on peut mettre
des petits coups de fouet à nos amis
allemands ? Euh comment on peut leur
expliquer que s'ils sont un peu trop
véhémments, on va leur couper le jus et
puis bah moi c'est exactement
l'inverse. C'estd que moi là je dis
alors les bon euh les chars à Paris en
1940 c'était pas sympa mais Frédéric
Mertz euh avocat éméné pendant 20 ans
euh président de Black Rock en Allemagne
pendant 10 ans pour gérer le bousin
européen pour résoudre notre problème de
dette souveraine en Europe. notre
surendettement pour remettre les gens au
travail, il y a pas mieux. Et vous voyez
ce qu'il fait en Allemagne. Donc moi le
l'anchelous l'anchlus il me va très bien
si le coup de téléphone lundi matin à 9h
à Ber voilà la tout dououlis pour la
semaine à faire et on arrête les
stupidités et vous faites le plan de 150
milliards d'économie qui a été écrit par
Jacques Delarios dans son livre le
déclin français est-il réversible ? on a
reçu ici que donc qui est le plan du
plan à la FMI puisque Jacques Dalusière
a dirigé le FMI et des crises
souveraines dans la vu toute sa vie. Ben
je dis si la solution ça passe par avoir
une petite piqû de rappel d'Allemagne
ben c'est très bien.
Donc ça est-ce que ça va passer par une
dévaluation massive de 20 à 30 % de
l'euro ? Ah alors ça c'est une bonne
réponse. On va ça va dépendre pardon,
c'est une bonne question. Le ça va tout
euh ça va dépendre de la manière dont
c'est traité. Le cas espagnol de 2010
vous donne une réponse, c'est que vous
pouvez faire une dévaluation interne.
Vous souvenez qu'en 2010 l'Espagne a
coupé les sales des fonctionnaires de 5
à 10 %. Elle dit la retraite passe de
mémoire c'était de 60 à 67 ans et euh on
coupe le budget de l'État de je sais
plus combien. Donc vous pouvez avoir un
un plan éphémie enfin type
interne qui fasse que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'évaluer tout l'euro. Mais par
contre et la réponse en fait elle va pas
venir de nous, elle va venir d'Allemagne
parce que c'est 1000 milliards d'euros
qui sont à dépenser. Tout dépend de la
manière dont l'Allemagne va les
investir. Si l'Allemagne les investit de
manière intelligente, l'Europe c'est la
Chine de 2008, c'est-à-dire que mais
sauf que la Chine a mal investi à
l'époque, mais on va être ceux qui de
manière totalement
paradoxale en fait vont rebondir puisque
les deux autres sont totalement
surendettés. À l'inverse, si l'Allemagne
fait n'importe quoi de ce milè et
devient un problème
supplémentaire de d'être
souveraine. Alors là, oui,
effectivement, bah c'est mitérant hein,
c'est la manière dont mes parents ont
été ruinés, c'est 82 83, vous faites -
20 - 20, vous êtes à - 35 et nous allons
tous perdre en euros - 35 % de notre
patrimoine. Il y a quelque chose qui
manque. Vous ne parlez pas d'énergie de
matière première dans le raisonnement de
soutenabilité des monnaies, dans le
raisonnement de projection de
l'économie. Pourtant c'est quand même
une pierre angulaire
fondamentale. Et c'est là où aussi on se
rend pas compte. Alors là euh la Chine
c'est
c'est en 2010 que ça commence hein. Euh
le mix vous prenez le mix énergétique de
2050,
l'or bleu, le net zéro.
Euh les les fossiles fiel, donc je sais
plus comment on dit en français, désolé
je les énergies fossiles les énergie
fossile merci passe de 80 % à 50 % du
mix énergétique. Vous avez 30 points de
différence sur ce changement de 30
points, vous en avez en fonction des
géographiques, vous regardez entre 15 et
20 qui viennent du
solaire. Le solaire en 2010, nous
européens à travers l'Allemagne, on
avait à peu près 60 % de part de marché
de l'équipement solaire.
Aujourd'hui, la Chine contrôle entre 2
et
3/4 de la chaîne de valeur de production
de l'industrie
solaire. Mais il y a un problème, c'est
que ça marche pas. C'est intermittent.
Il y a pas de modèle économique. Donc il
vous faut le stockage de l'énergie. Vous
l'avez vu en Espagne d'où les barrages.
Non, on vient de le voir en Espagne. En
Espagne, il surtout les gigab, je sais
pas pourquoi. D'où d'où les gigabies ?
les gigabries mais surtout l'or bleu les
barrages hydrauliques. Non mais ça ça
viendra les barrages hydrauliques vient
les barrages hydrauliques sont déjà
faits euh en Chine. Alors euh là vous en
avez un gratiné qui vient. Si vous aimez
les barrages hydraulique, j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous, c'est que il y a le
plus grand du monde qui a été approuvé
de manière assez sympathique le 25
décembre 2024 pendant que madame Iskay
était en train de préparer le réveillon.
Non, c'est qui prépare le réveillon.
C'est vous qui préparez le réveillon.
Bah parfait. Et du coup, vous l'avez pas
vu, mais la Chine a annoncé le plus
grand barrage du monde qui est trois
fois celui c'est 60 GW au Tibet à la
frontière de l'Inde de manière à piquer
l'eau. Vous savez que le Tibet c'est pas
une question de bouddhisme catarisme
Bukoshiwa, c'est de l'eau pour 40 % de
la population. C'est pas une question de
moine en to et en tongue. Alors ça joue
aussi puisque nous y sommes très
sensibles mais il y a également il y a
également une question d'eau et donc ce
barrage a été annoncé le 25 décembre
2024 et vous aurez noté que personne
n'en parle. Qu'est-ce qui alors que ça
va être potentiellement la source du
conflit entre l'Inde et l'chien. Oui oui
oui puis des le enfin une des sources
l'Inde aussi beaucoup de chef. Vous
m'avez m'a interrompu mais juste pour
juste pour finir la Chine a aussi
annoncé la création de réacteur et de
réacteur autorium.
Oui. Alors ça j'ai pas suivi parce que
je suis pas juste pour finir sur le
stellaire parce que le c'est quand même
le plus grand changement de mix
énergétique. Euh CATL et BID vont faire
des gigabes où ils vont être a priori
sauf si sursaut hein très très en avance
sur nous. Ce qui fait que en
250 euh je sais pas comment il
s'appelle, Skaito ou Skaita, votre
petite fille ou votre petitfils en 2050
là la
Chine sera l'Arabie Saoudite de
1973 en nous disant ben le facteur de
décarbonisation le plus important c'est
le salaire. Et donc et donc bah si vous
n'êtes pas gentil, je peux vous couper
l'équipement, je peux vous couper les
gigabatteries et donc vous êtes gentil
avec quand vous dites gentil, vous êtes
soumis. C'est ça. C'est ça. C'est-à-dire
que l'économie de guerre, ce qui est
important dépendance et donc il y a plus
de s là où on raisonne de manière à mon
avis erronée, c'est qu'on parle de
souveraineté dans le monde dans lequel
on est. Il n'y a pas de Le dernier type
qui a dit qu'il était souverain, c'est
Luis X. On lui a coupé la tête. Je vous
conseille pas de c'est pas très bon de
dire qu'on est souverain. Par contre
travailler sur les interdépendances ça
c'est ce qui m'occupe toute la journée.
Alors on va ouvrir une parenthèse pour
mieux cerner votre façon de penser et
l'arborescence et la construction de
votre pensée. Vous faites comment pour
vous informer ? Ah ! Alors ça c'est
absolument génial parce que c'est la
question que me pose, je fais beaucoup
de conférences à des 20 25
ans et je trouve ça absolument c'est
toujours j'apprends énormément et à
chaque fois chaque fois il me disent
toujours mais comment vous faites pour
vous informer ? Parce qu'ils sont tous
abonnés chez Scurview. J'ai une j'ai la
fille de copains qui a lu mon livre qui
est à brillantissime qui est à ScienceP
et qui elle m'a dit "Mais ton livre
c'est l'inverse de la brillantissime à
Science Po". Oui, ben justement ben il y
en a justement il y en a quelques-uns
qui résistent et elle m'a dit "Mais ton
livre c'est l'inverse de ce tout ce
qu'on lit dans les journaux. D'où ça
sort ?" Alors pourquoi votre livre il a
pas voulu les éditeurs français ont pas
voulu le publier ? Vous avez été obligé
de le faire publier sur chez un éditeur
qui ne publie que des textes refusés ?
Alors effectivement, j'ai une chance
incroyable, c'est que la maison
Novis a accepté de me publier quand tout
le monde refusait de me publier. Alors
taper la porte de chez qui ? Alors euh
ça je vais pas vous dire mais le ce qui
est plus important c'est que moi j'avais
comme vision du métier d'éditeur que
c'était des vieux schnok qui éditaient
des jeunes esprits brillantissimes. Et
moi, c'est un jeune esprit
brillantissime qui édite le vieux schn
parce que mon éditeur a la moitié de mon
âge. Et donc je pense il a 55 ans.
Voilà c'est programme
chinois les démocraties sont comme les
poissons. Elles pourissent par la tête.
et que donc bah pourquoi ? Parce que
quand j'écris que le SG c'est énergie,
sécurité, guerre, j'ai des éditeurs qui
me disent "Ah non mais ça on peut pas on
peut pas mais parce que ça va passer. Ça
va pas passer auprès de qui ?" Mais
auprès du lectorat. C'est alors ça la
réponse vous l'avez de Thomas Friedman.
Le énergie sécurité guerre c'est un
chapitre dans votre livre. Oui mais je
réponds d'abord à votre question. Euh
Thomas Friedman du New York Times
explique le problème. Donc c'est un prix
pu dire, c'est un des journalistes.
Filiation, une filiation de Robert,
enfin je sais pas, je connais pas le
l'arbre généalogique
mais c'est une des stars du New York
Times et il dit en fait mon métier a
totalement changé le jour où Zuckenberg
a inventé like parce qu'avant mon
rédacteur en chef venait me voir, il me
disait si tu veux un article en première
page, il faut que tu arrives avec une
idée qui n'a jamais été traitée partout
dans le monde. et autrement tu as pas un
article. Et il dit maintenant il vient
me voir et il me dit combien tu as eu de
likes la semaine dernière parce qu'en
fonction de tes likes, je te donne ou
non la première page. Il dit le seul
moyen d'avoir des likes c'est de vous
dire ce que vous connaissez déjà parce
que vous avez l'impression d'être
intelligent. Donc moi la manière dont je
m'informe c'est malheureusement quand
j'étais étudiant je lisais le monde
parce qu'il y avait l'éditorial d'André
Fontaine qui était un concent une fois
par mois il y avait un concentré
d'intelligence qui me faisait réfléchir
pendant tout un mois.
Aujourd'hui, il y a plus de monopole du
savoir et vous êtes obligé de
diversifier vos sources. Alors, je paye
très très cher pour avoir
Bloomberg. Donc, Bloomberg, c'est très
cher de 2000 € par
mois. L'info, elle est pas elle est pas
si elle est gratose, c'est toi le
produit, hein. Mais il y a aussi d'en
profite pour dire à notre communauté,
financez-nous sur Tipi parce que vous
n'êtes pas le produit. Vous permettez à
des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens aussi
d'avoir accès à des interviews de
monsieur Bavrez et et d'autres prix
Nobel
d'économie. On a reçu Stitz ici qui
était sur ce siège là. On a une mais
c'est pour ça que j'admire ce que vous
faites. C'est pour ça que j'ai donc
Financez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous. On ne prend pas la la YouTube
monnaie, la Google monnaie, on ne met
pas de pub et et malgré le fait que des
annonceurs tapent à notre porte pour
mettre de la pub, on préfère avancer en
phalange avec notre communauté. On prend
pas de subvention, on paye la TVA à 20
%. Nos finances sont transparentes, on
paye une expert comptable, on paye un
avocat, on paye nos nos techniciens et
donc merci. Grâce à vous, on peut
exister. La leçon, vous lisez et à la
fin vous écoutez un podcast, est-ce que
j'ai appris quelque chose ? Si vous
n'avez rien appris, vous laissez tomber.
Faut faire la même chose avec la presse
française aussi.
Bien sûr. Non, mais c'est vous saz,
j'écris dans l'opinion chaque mois
gratuitement. parce que je veux défendre
ce que je crois un journal
extraordinaire qui est très ouvert sur
tout le monde. Vous avez prenez le
journal l'Express, c'est un en fait
c'est une place de marché à la fois de
journalistes et d'experts qui ne sont
pas journalistes et
qui était un pilier de l'express et des
échos. Donc on peut on me prend 15
heures par jour, vous voyez, c'est
pas malheureusement euh il y a pas de
prête à manger. Est-ce que vous vous
discutez avec d'autres personnes de
votre calibre, investisseurs ou
travaillant dans la finance ? 55 kg en
général, les gens sont plus ils sont
plus pèent plus que moi. Mais je parle
oui au maximum de gens. Est-ce que vous
avez des gens qui essayent de vous
expliquer que bah vous êtes à côté de la
plaque ou vous avez vrai vous avez pas
vrai ? Alors bien sûr euh la la
meilleure euh critique que j'ai reçu de
mon livre, c'est un jeune brillantissime
qui est un entrepreneur en Asie qui a
une trentaine d'années et qui m'a dit
"Ton bouquin, j'ai adoré, je l'ai lu en
un weekend, mais euh tu es vraiment
complètement à côté de la plaque parce
que tu as vraiment rien compris. La
première partie du livre où tuexpliques
ce qui se passe. Bon, je trouvais ça
passionnant mais la seconde partie qui
donne des pistes de réflexion sur
comment agir, c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi. Parce que tu fais référence à des
partis politiques, aux entreprises, aux
ONG, aux tank et toutes ces
institutions. Mais à ma génération, on n
veut plus.
Et moi la manière, il m'a dit mais moi
la manière dont je gère ma boîte, c'est
que je monte un projet, je vais sur le
réseau en disant euh qui vient pour le
projet. Les gens viennent pour 6 9 mois
et puis ensuite ils partent. Et puis
ensuite je leur dis bah quand j'aurai un
nouveau un nouveau projet, je vous je
vous convoquerai. Et la preuve que vous
avez sur les Jeux Olympiques et Notre
Dame, c'est deux seuls trucs qu'on a
vraiment où on a scotché le monde. La
France a scotché le monde. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'il y a eu deux projets sur
lesquels on a fédéré les gens et on a
respecté aucune norme. Donc les Jeux
Olympiques, moi j'adore, c'est quand on
a dit "Ouais, français, vous avez été
formidable." C'est quoi la véritable
histoire des Jeux Olympiques que j'ai
été qu'on m'a confirmé la semaine
dernière au mois d'octobre 2023, il y a
une réunion, un comité interministériel.
Il se passe que on dit on ne sera jamais
prêt et que le gouvernement dit le seul
moyen d'être prêt c'est d'appeler une
vingtaine de pas de préfets mais de
sous-préfet de province qui sont les
types qui se paluchent nos
administrations tous les jours. des
opératifs des des ce qu'on appelle dans
le jargon les chief operating officers
et qui viennent et qui ont
dit whatever it takes vous faites ce que
vous voulez vous ne respectez aucune
norme mais il y a les Jeux Olympiques au
mois de juin si vous parlez à tous les
gens qui organisé les Jeux olympiques de
octobre 2023 à juin 2024 aucune règle
n'a été respectée. Notre Dame le général
en chef il n'a respecté aucune règle
c'est pour ça que ça a été fait en 5 ans
alors que le chantier devait durer 10
ans. Donc vous voyez bien que dès
qu'on transforme ce pays, qu'on ne
respecte plus aucune des normes
complètement débiles qu'on nous impose,
on est champion du monde et je le dis
sans arrogance. Donc revenons à votre
ami en Asie qui est un riche
entrepreneur de 30 ans. Pourquoi il vous
dit euh les sing tank, les journaux, les
partis politiques ? Parce que il m'a
prévenu de mon voyage à Strasbourg la
semaine dernière.
Donc la semaine dernière, je suis invité
à parler au à 250 top dirigeants du
numérique en France et il se trouve que
la réunion est au Parlement de
Strasbourg et je n'étais jamais au
Parlement de Strasbourg de ma vie. Donc
je veux au Parlement de Strasbourg. Ils
ont la gentillesse de me payer le train
et j'ai un taxi qui m'attend à la gare
et je prends le taxi pour aller à 2h de
l'après-midi à ma conférence que je
parlais à 4h. Et donc il y a un quart
d'heure de trajet et au bout de 5
minutes, je ne vois pas une voiture, pas
une voiture dans je dis mais je sais pas
quoi, le maire de Strasbourg est mort,
le cardinal est mort. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Il y a il y a enfin pourquoi ?
Et le taxi me dit non mais c'est pas de
la
semaine. Mais comment ça c'est pas la
semaine ? On est jeudi. Pourquoi c'est
pas la semaine ? C'est pas la semaine où
les députés européens sont là.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire des
députés européens ? Il dit bah oui, les
députés européens, ils sont là une
semaine par mois, les trois autres
semaines, ils sont à
Bruxelles. Donc je rentre dans le
parlement, je vois les gens quand il la
conférence et je dis mais donc h étages
de building en une cathédrale totalement
vite sauf des 250. Et je dis mais oui,
ils sont tous à Bruxelles. Et donc je
dit mais vous connaissez une
boîte qui a deux sièges sociaux et qui
chaque mois dit la 4e semaine on va tous
prendre l'avion pendant 300 km
pour aller dans l'autre siège social.
Donc, j'en suis sorti en disant "Mais
comment puis-je mettre dans la tête de
850 députés européens qu'il faut qu'on
se réveille et qu'il faut que nous
revoyons notre modèle économique quand
eux trouvent tout à fait normal d'avoir
deux sièges sociaux à je sais pas
combien 200 300 km de distance et qui
font
ça la dernière semaine de chaque mois."
Donc je me suis dit là c'est foutu donc
il va falloir qu'on raisonne autrement.
Donc les singtang sont caduc, les médias
sont caduc, les partis politiques sont
caduc. Ben quand vous avez euh c'est
c'est le président
d'AXA, vous savez AXA donc AXA c'est le
plus gros assureur français chaque année
remet un rapport sur les risques
et ce président Thomas qui est un
allemand a dit on lui a posé la question
quel est le plus gros risque en France
sous-estimé ? répondu, c'est le risque
d'implosion sociale parce que il n'y a
plus de contrat
sociétal. Je trouve que la même semaine,
j'ai lu un rapport de l'INC, vous avez
sans doute
lu. Si vous êtes un jeune de moins de 30
ans enfant ou une jeune et que vous avez
un CDI, donc vous êtes vous êtes
quelqu'un d'extrêmement brillant parce
qu'avoir un CDI aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout facile comparé à quand moi je
sortais de l'école. Vous recevez en
moyenne mensuellement 305 € de soutien
familial.
parce qu'autrement vous pouvez pas finir
le mois mais travailleur pauvre. Donc
comment voulez-vous que quelqu'un qui a
qui a moins de 30 ans qui a
réussi a confiance dans des institution
qui fait que même quand il a réussi et
l'article expliqué à quel point c'était
humiliant en fait d'aller déjeuner chez
grand-mère à la fin du mois qui était
autrement très agréable mais à la fin du
repas elle donnait une petite enveloppe
et c'était humiliant sans elle en fait
je boucle pas le mois donc là vous voyez
que le contrat sociétal il est pété donc
on va pas pouvoir alors je rajoute une
autre statistique Moi qui m'a beaucoup
frappé, j'ai pas réalisé, c'est que vous
prenez 18 30 ans en France, il y en a 50
% qui n'ont pas poursuivi leurs études
au-delà du bac. Alors, je veux pas jouer
les diplômés arrogants en disant il faut
avoir quatre diplômes. Mais je dis quand
même alors ça vous empêche pas d'être
potentiellement premier ministre hein.
Donc ça veut dire que vous n'alz pas
réussir dans la vie. Mais quand même
premier ministre à son bac, il a fait la
zatienne. Non mais il y en a un
potentiel. Il y a un premier ministre
potentiel d'après ce que je comprends
qui a arrêté ses études au bac.
euh je crois qu'il s'appelle Bardella.
C'est ça le euh et donc ceux qui sont
allés ceux qui sont arrêtés c'est que
soit soit ils n'ont pas été formés parce
que ils ont eu le bac, soit ils ont fait
une filière technique et donc on les a
formé à on leur a pas appris à
apprendre, on leur a appris une
technicité et si par hasard il y a une
révolution technologique qui fait que
cette technologie meurt, on peut pas que
ce sont des nomades dans notre jargon.
Il y a des
nomades et les pas ce sont les
sédentaires qui peuvent pas
bouger et les nomades comme moi qui ont
été formé qui parlent anglais qui
peuvent si la France s'écoule, je peux
aller un autre part et puis on
recommencera.
Et donc vous voyez
que ben s'il y a pas de modèle social
pour quelqu'un qui a 18 30 ans, il y a
pas de modèle social pour notre société.
Et Marcel Gauchet dit c'est l'erreur que
nous
commettons. Pour que ça aille mieux pour
vos
enfants, faudra que ça aille mieux aussi
pour les enfants des autres. Donc nous
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit on met le
paquet sur nos
enfants, l'éducation nationale n'éduque
pas suffisant bien. Ben on prend des
cours du soir, on je sais pas quoi, on
les met dans l'école privée et cetera.
Je fais des Ça c'est la class qui fait
ça. Exactement. C'est les 50 % qui s'en
tirent mais on s'occupe pas des 50
autres. Et donc pour ça, il y a des
solutions dans mon bouquin. Donc ça peut
pas fonctionner. Exactement.
Donc donc on est quelque part là je
reviens je viens très francofrançais
pour moi. Alors je suis désé mais je
suis
très je suis je vis pas dans ce pays.
Donc ce que je vous raconte ça va
peut-être vous sir un truc de venir.
Mais la grande différence quand j'arrive
à Hong Kong je suis en zone de non
confort. J'atterris je suis en zone de
zone confort parce que je suis en
économie de guerre et je dis quel est le
truc que les Chinois et les américains
sont en train de se où est-ce qu'on va
péter ? Quand j'atti à Paris, je suis en
zone de total
confort parce que tout va bien, les
boutiques sont les mêmes, on a changé
les il fait beau, les terrasses, tout le
monde, les cafés sont pleins en
permanence, les restos sont pleins, tout
va bien. C'est à Paris ça. Oui.
Et et c'est justement parce qu'on se
rend pas compte du reste quoi. Et donc
on est en mélange pour moi de
1940 et 1958.
la racine de la question, c'est-à-dire
comment vous informez ? Donc vous m'avez
dit vous payez 2000 balles Bloomberg.
Est-ce que vous avez des sondes autres
que vos copains investisseurs ou vos
copains expat ? Alors vous avez d'abord
pour rassurer les gens, il y a pas
besoin d'être dans les services secrets
et d'être au SS 118. Vous avez je crois
non vous serez 118 montez en
gamme. Vous avez énormément
d'informations de très très haute
qualité en open source. En open source.
Parce que vous avez des chercheurs, vous
avez des vous avez vous avez des un
patron un patron français d'une très
grosse boîte qui fait du renseignement
économique ou de l'intelligence
économique dit que 95 % de l'information
est en open source.
Mais je pense qu'il a raison
aujourd'hui. C'est le c'est la beauté du
net, c'est que vous avez des gens
extrêmement brillants, extrêmement
intelligents qui disent "Je vais
partager" et notamment comment vous
expliquez que les les les la France, le
gouvernement français et on va dire les
Européens Bruxelles, Strasbourg apporen,
appelez ça comme vous voulez. Comment
vous expliquez que on a l'impression
qu'ils sont au milieu du gay ? Vous avez
dit que Vlen proposait aux chinois zéro
de W douan si j'ai bien compris.
sacrifia l'industrie allemande euh au
passage l'industrie automobile
allemande. Comment vous expliquez-vous
depuis votre balcon
asiatique que notre classe politique si
bien potentiellement si bien renseignée,
si bien informé avec des notes de Bercy
sur les recettes, les dépenses, les
prévisions et j'en passai des meilleurs
et l'anticipation de la guerre et j'en
passé des meilleurs et l'anticipation
énergétique et j'en passé des meilleurs.
Comment ça se fait que la France a la
156 milliards de balances commerciale
dans le rouge que ça commence à tirer un
peu la langue un peu partout ? Comment
vous expliquez qu' on est au milieu de
d'une guerre
économique on voit rien, on anticipe
rien et que le les journalistes en
général continuent la petite musique que
on est les plus forts, que notre
ministre est le meilleur et que tout ira
bien. Alors, mis à part quelques-uns qui
commencent
à à tirer la langue avec, comment vous
vous percevez ça ? Comment ça se fait ?
Alors, ça se fait qu'à ma
génération, on les gens brillants sont
allés dans le business et qu'on a
sous-traité la politique à des gens que
je veux pas dénigrer mais j'appellerai
médiocre. C'est c'est pas des mauvais,
c'est pas des bons, moins équipés. Non,
ils sont pas moins équipés mais ils sont
pas agiles. Ils ont Non, mais ils ont un
biais, ils ont un biais cognitif. OK.
Alors là, on va remonter, je crois que
c'est fin des années 90, la Bible, c'est
Jean-François Rebel, la connaissance
inutile. C'est-à-dire que je vous mets,
vous arrivez avec la vraie info, elle me
plaît pas. C'est un gros biais
d'investisseur hein, c'est le la
négation de la réalité et la négation de
la mauvaise nouvelle qui vous fait pas
plaisir. Donc, j'investis entre dans des
startup. La définition de la start-up
qui est réussie, il y a qu'une, c'est la
vitesse à laquelle la nouvelle négative
voyage. Et ça vaut dans les très grands
groupes, c'est la même chose. Dans les
très grands groupes, vous passez toute
votre vie à essayer de planquer au
patron ce qui marche pas et lui faire
croire que tout va bien. Et le patron de
génie, c'est celui qui est suffisamment
qui crée suffisamment une équipe autour
de lui confiance en disant "Moi, j'ai eu
mon premier patron, il m'a dit c'était
j'ai fait mon service militaire dans
coopération. Je travaillais pour le le
directeur qui dirigeait Renault au
Royaume-Uni à l'époque où Renault était
en faillite et les voitures avaient
plutôt trois roues que quatre roues. Et
il m'avait dit "Je ne veux que des
mauvaises nouvelles." Les bonnes
nouvelles, elles arriveront à moi. Je ne
veux que les mauvaises nouvelles. Je
veux qu'elle me remonte le plus vite
possible.
par une mauvaise nouvelle donc j'ai j'ai
des copains qui travaillent dans le
ministère, ils disent entre la note que
j'écrit pour le ministre et celle qui
atterrit dans son bureau qui passe par 4
c échelons, ils enlèvent tout ce qui est
intelligent parce que tout ce qui fait
mal et donc le ministre reçoit une note
qui dit tout va bien, il faut les virer
ces gens-là. Ah ben justement c'est ça
s'appelle ça. Alors ça s'appelle
éphémie. Alors il y a il y a une autre
solution et c'est pour ça que moi je
pense qu'on est euh je pense qu'on est
enfin j'étais pas là mais ça me rappelle
ce que j'ai lu dans les livres
d'histoire 1940 1958. Je pense qu'on est
à la fin d'un
régime. La 5e République repose sur
l'homme ou la femme providentielle. En
fait ça n'existe pas. Ça existe pas en
France mais ça existe nulle part dans le
monde. Et donc l'espoir de penser qu'il
y a quelqu'un de fantastique qui va et
alors je vais vous donner une idée qui
va vous paraître totalement sagrenue
mais prenez deux pays totalement
différents. Peut pas trouver deux pays
plus extrêmes. La Chine et la
Suisse. OK. Énorme pays dictature he ou
régime très fort tout petit
pays votation tous les ultime démocratie
vocation tous les dimanches ils ont une
communalité ils investissent dans l'ord
non alors oui entre autres mais en terme
de gouvernance c'est que l'organe ultime
de décision est composé de cette
personn secret de la réussite des
start-up c'est qu'il faut que vous ayez
un conseil d'administration
composé de 3 5 ou 7 personnes. S'il y a
une 8e personne dans un conseil
d'administration, vous démissionnez
parce que la 8e fout le bordel,
n'apporte absolument rien à la
discussion et veut juste [__] son
grain de sel pour dire je suis moi aussi
tranquille impère nombre impère et il y
a pas un problème au monde où cette
personne avec des horizons différentes
n'arrivent pas à avoir la bonne
solution.
Donc ces
sep ces sep personnes standing comité
donc comité permanent en Chine, je sais
plus comment s'appelle confédération
conseil de la confédération elvétique
pourquoi on les met pas en France Comité
de salut publique donc réfléchissons de
quoi avons-nous besoin défense sécurité
intérieure économie donc énergie
financez
énergie éducation santé tout le reste.
Ça viendra après parce que on est en
crise, il a
urgence. Donc ce qu'on fait, comment les
nommer
? Ben on prend, je vous ai dit que mon
copain de 30 ans, il a plus confiance
dans la moindre institution. Donc on se
dit "Mais qui a confiance dans les
institutions aujourd'hui en France ?
Quelles institutions ont résisté ?"
L'armée. L'armée à tort ou raison, les
Français ont confiance dans l'armée.
L'armée a confiance en qui ? qui en 2017
a dit monsieur le président de la
République le villier il y aura je suis
désolé c'est la voyez je vous dis la
mauvaise nouvelle qui voyage il y aura
sous votre kainquen il y a une très très
forte probabilité qu'il y ait un conflit
terrestre donc il me faut des moyens
parce que l'armée française général
deilier il a été viré tout de suite.
Donc les Français ont confiance dans
l'armée l'armée a confiance dans le
général de viier général de viier il
retraite. Donc dit mon général c'est pas
vous mais dites-nous vous connaissez
l'état de la défense française vous
connaissez vous avez été vous avez vu le
truc que personne n'ait vu. Qui
mettez-vous le 40 50 ans qui va bosser ?
Ensuite les finances les français ont
confiance à raison dans la Banque de
France. OK. La Banque de France c'est
celui qui anticipé une croissance à
combien de pourcent ? Non mais c'est
comment il s'appelle lui ? Peu importe
on a confiance. On a on a on a
confiance. Ouais. Le président de la
Banque de France qui nous annoncé un
tout Ouais. Mais qui a fait un super
discours à New York il y a 2 jours,
c'est lui qui est rentré dans l'art de
ou d'accord. D'accord. Très bien. Donc
on a confiance. Donc la Banque de France
a confiance en qui ? Vous l'avez nommé
précédemment Jacques Dearosier 95 ans.
C'est retard lui. Bon lui même truc
tonton Flingueer comme Général Devilier
il dit on lui dit "Monsieur le
gouverneur qui vous voyez pour diriger
les finances Aucun risque qu'il dise
Bruno Lemer parce que quand on lui
demander quel est le bilan de Bruno
Lemire, il a dit
déplorable. Donc il saura choisir la
bonne personne. Et donc vous faites ça
avec les sept ces sep fonctions. Vous
faites un binôme de d'un tonton
flingueur que ou d'une tata flingueuse
que toute la France respecte qui est une
notoriété morale et qui nomme un 40 50
ans. Et vous avez un comité de salut
public qui prend des décisions
collégiales à 4 contre 3 et alors ça va
pas être G.
Parce que l'alternative, est-ce que vous
avez rencontré la vice-présidente du
MEDF Suédois au mois de janvier quand
elle est venue à Paris ? Et ben oui.
Fabuleuse. Fabuleuse. Absolument génial.
Euh un petit peu austère quand même. Ah
bah moyennement drôle quand euh ça Oui,
les blagues, il vaut mieux il vaut mieux
aller en Italie qu'en Suède. Les Suédois
on ont on un super sens de l'humour mais
c'est le modèle européen et elle elle
vous explique queil faut il faut quatre
conditions. La France doit remplir
quatre conditions pour se réformer parce
que c'était celle de la Suède en 90.
Lutherrien en Suède ? Non. Alors je sais
pas ils sont il doit y avoir un peu de
Vous croyez en Dieu ? Alors, je suis euh
croyant, pas pratiquant, voyez. Donc euh
je suis un sympathisant comme disait euh
je ne suis je ne suis je ne suis qu'un
sympathisant. Ça vous arrange. Voilà.
Euh quatre conditions. Premièrement, il
faut que la crise, il faut qu'il y ait
une crise souveraine parce que les Vous
croyez au rebond du champ.
Attendez, je vais vous dire les quatre
conditions. On va voir si on les a
remplit. Premièrement, il faut qu'il y
ait une crise souveraine. On l'a pas, on
peut pas être productif. Non, on verra.
On aura peut-être l'an prochain.
Deuxièmement, il faut que vous
ayez les parties du centre qui s'allent
contre les extrêmes. Donc ce que les
Allemands appellent la grosse coalition,
le SPD avec bon chez nous, on pour
l'instant on va pas trop
l'avir. Il y a Bloomberg, une rumeur de
Bloomberg il y a 3 jours qui dit il y a
une dissolution au mois d'octobre. Il y
aura une il y a un rêve de gros. Bon
très bien. Oui. Alors Churchill euh ne
croyait jamais une annonce officielle
tant qu'elle n'a pas été au moins
démentie cinq fois. Donc vous pouvez
continuer, vous encore avoir quatre
fois. 3è condition, il faut
comme cette coalition va prendre des
mesures qui vont être
pénibles, qui sont contrariantes, il
faut que vous ayez des syndicats
extrêmement forts, extrêmement bien tenu
qui donc Volkswagen, voyez Volkswagen,
il y a cogestion, ils font les syndicats
bloquent tout pendant 10 ans, 10 ans,
pas de licenciement, job garanti pendant
10 ans. Et là, ils viennent d'annoncer,
on vient 30 % des gens en Allemagne et
les gens disent "Bah comme ça vient des
syndicats". OK. Dernier point, flex
sécurité comme je vous vire, ce qui est
pas très
gai. J'ai
identifié les nouveaux jobs. Alors, je
vous recase à entre 60 et 80 % de votre
salaire précédent, mais je vous forme à
un nouveau métier, même si vous avez
plus de 55 ans. Donc la France, vous
prenez les 60 65 ans, il y en a un tiers
qui travaille, ensuite c'est 90. La
différence en terme de revenu pour
l'État et cotisation qui rentre et
retraite en moins, c'est 130 milliards
d'euros. C'est notre déficit public.
Vous êtes en train de comparer les les
chou-fleurs avec les radis là ? Non, je
suis en train de vous comparer des
Suédois et des Français et je vous dis
bah voilà pourquoi la Suède l'a fait.
Alors aujourd'hui juste la Suède gaz en
Suède, ils ont des hydrocarbures en
Suède souvent en Suède non c'est les
Norvégiens quand sont boués mais ils
sont sympa avec les Norvégiens donc ça
se passe très bien. Non la Suède ils ont
surtout 2 % de gain de productivité
annuel depuis 1990. C'est-à-dire que
c'est la partie européenne qui est à
égalité sont une dizaine de millions.
Ils sont à égalité avec les US. Ils ont
alors pourquoi suisse les Suisses vous
êtes un peu en dessous. Je crois que
vous êtes 7 8 millions. Vous êtes
peut-être à 10 français. Ah, je vous le
fais. Allez, vous êtes un bon client. Je
vous le fais à 60
millions. Non, vous avez
65. P Il y a combien de personnes qui
payent l'impôt sur le revenu en France ?
Ah euh bah beaucoup trop euh mais je
crois qu'il y en a la moitié qui le
payent pas de mémoire. Il y a combien de
personnes qui gagnent autour de 2200 €
par mois en France ? Alors, salir médian
1900 a priori puis vous avez 1000 de
prestations. Combien de personnes qui
gagnent 2200 € par mois ? Ah combien de
alors au chiffre près, ça je pourrais
pas vous le dire. Euh 50 % je demande à
me faire fa checker. Oui. Le le salaire
médian de se passe si on se prend 25 le
salaire médian, ça veut dire qu'il y a
50 % au dessus, 50 %. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe si on se reprend 25 % 20 à 25 %
d'inflation euh euh sur notre classe
moyenne ? Et ben c'est comme ça qu'on va
s'en sortir. Ah bon ? Ben oui, mais la
seule manière de s'en sortir, c'est ce
qu'on connaiss la thermodynamique.
Allez-y. L'instabilité en
thermodynamique, qu'est-ce que ça fait ?
Ouais. Ça fait quoi ? Allez-y. Ça
explose. Alors, ça explose parce que euh
vous n'avez pas expliqué aux gens
pourquoi on faisait des choses. Donc la
seule manière de s'en sortir, c'est 1945
1951.
On était combien à cette époque-là en
France ? Ouf ! Alors là, j' étais pas
euh je sais pas combien était 20 30
millions. Je sais
pas. Mais c'est pas une question de
nombre. Encore une fois, je vous ai
montré, je vous ai montré la Suisse, on
était bouté d'qu Non mais c'est le c'est
l'argument. Ouais, il y a que Singapour
qui peut faire, il y a que de toute
façon soit les pays sont trop grands,
soit ils sont trop petits. Donc on peut
jamais faire. Donc là, on arrête. En
train de vous passer en stress test là.
Non, mais on arrête, il y a aucun il y a
zéro souci. Je vous dis juste que euh et
du coup, j'ai perdu le fil, la manière
la manière dont on va s'en sortir, ce
sont les taux d'intérêt réel négatif.
C'estàd que vous êtes
retraité, vous voulez pas que je vous p
je vous baisse vos retraites. Donc
personne qui gagne 700 € par mois en
tant que retraite.
Alors ça, je saurais pas vous dire. Je
sais qu'en moyenne à retraité gagne plus
qu'un actif, ça je suis au
courant. Donc c'est un peu pour ça qu'on
a un petit problème. Et la manière dont
on va résoudre le problème, c'est qu'on
va faire une inflation de plus de 5 % et
qu'on va maintenir les retraites stables
et donc les retraités vont perdre 5 %
par ils dépent 25
%. Donc les 25 % c'est quoi ? C'est 500
€. Je vous ai dit que le petit enfant il
lui manque 305 € donc tout concorde je
vais euh Grandma Sky Grandma Sky
102 ans hier d'ailleurs et je l'embrasse
alors ça c'est et je sais qu'elle nous
regarde en direct que c'est une femme de
tête et mamie je t'aime et encore bonne
animation et donc quand elle voit euh
Petit quand elle voit Petit Sky qui a du
mal à finir ses fins de mois, elle est
prête à lui donner je pense qu'elle
continue à vous donner 305 € Si vous lui
dites "Mamie, j'arrive pas à boucler mes
fins de moi." Donc les grands Non mais
que les grands-mères et les grands-pères
soient des salot égoïstes qui refusent
de donner quoi que ce soit aux
générations d'après, ça n'existe pas. Et
je vais vous montrer, je vais vous
raconter un truc, c'est pour ça que
potentiellement je suis super boulish.
Je je vais je vais essayer de vous on va
jouer on va jouer genre si vous montez
votre voix je continue à
question on prend pas de prosac ici.
Juste une question quand vous avez euh
les grands-parents qui donnent 300
balles à à leurs petits enfants, si vous
leur baissez votre retraite, est-ce
qu'ils vont toujours garder votre leurs
petits-enfants ? Est-ce qu'ils vont
est-ce qu'ils vont toujours donner 305
balles ou est-ce que c'est pas les
jeunes actifs qui vont être obligés de
prendre soin plus de leurs
grands-parents ? Est-ce que c'est pas
improductif de baisser la retraite ?
Alors la réponse vous l'avez, faut être
concret hein, vous l'avez en 2024. Donc
le président Macron en 2022 dans mon
jargon de business, il avait 30 % de
part de marché. Il a eu 30 % des voix en
gros à la présidentielle. 2 ans plus
tard, il a eu 15 % des voix. Donc moi,
une société qui perd la moitié de sa
part de marché en 2 ans quand il est il
est leader du marché, c'est qu'il y a
une disruption massive. De ce que j'ai
lu et je suis pas super politologue, les
15 points qu'il a perdu la moitié sont
des gens qui ont été laminés par la
mondialisation, les Chinois qui
débarquent peut-être et l'autre matière
sont les retraités. Alors pourquoi 1er
janvier, il les a augmenté de 5 %. en
disant je les augmente de 5 % comme ça
je suis sûr qu'il vote pour moi.
Supportation de vote et il a eu l'idée
alors c'est pas lui mais il y a un
monsieur qui est arrivé qui fait des
sondage et qui lui a dit au mois d'avril
je vais te faire
l'apprèsvente quand même vérifier que tu
gagnes les élections je vais aller les
voir et vérifier que ils sont bien
contents. Donc je vais voir entre autres
donc vous l'appelez c'est qui c'est
Grand Maskaille et je vais voir Grand
Maskaille. Je lui dis Grand Maskaille
comment ça va ? Mais elle me dit je dors
plus la nuit.
la moitié disent je ne dors plus la nuit
la moitié mais pourquoi vous augmenté de
5 % je rappelle que les gens qui bossent
ils ont eu de et demi donc je augmenté
deux fois plus que ceux qui bossent elle
dit c'est bien pour ça que je dors
plus parce que je lis dans tous les
journaux depuis 2 3 ans que mon système
de retraite il est plus financé alors en
l'occurrence j'ai pas 103 ans, j'ai 75
ans, j'ai une espérance de vie à 82 donc
je pense que je vais vivre encore 7 ans.
Et là, je n'ai lu nulle part que vous
avez augmenté le financement de
l'organisme de retraite. Donc, j'ai un
chapelet avec lequel je prie tous les
jours pour que ça tienne encore 7 ans et
là vous m'augmentez de 5 ans sans
augmenter le financement. Donc le truc
mais il va peut-être péter l'an
prochain. Donc je ne dors plus la nuit.
Deuxème question. Ma grand-mère, elle
dort un peu plus parce qu'elle a fait
une petite retraite par capitalisation.
Et ben voilà. Et ben fabuleux. Bah parce
que son petitfils lui a tout expliqué.
C'est pour ça que c'est ma grand-mère
qui m'a expliqué la finance. Fabieux.
Euh ben l'air top, n'en changez pas
hein. Non non fabuleux. Deuxème question
euh Grand Maskaille, comme je t'ai
augmenté, tu as 5 % de plus, où est-ce
que tu vas dépenser l'argent ? Dit mais
j'ai pas son autonomie mais pas du tout,
j'ai pas d'argent potentiellement l'an
prochain, j'économise tout. Taux
dépargne des retraités 25 %. 25 %.
Donc toute l'augmentation va dans un
taux d'épargne pour acheter les 300
milliards de dettes et continuer la G.
Donc donc ce qu'il y a d'extraordinaire,
c'est que sur non mais sur le plan, il
faut que vous mettiez ça dans sur le
plan
politique le coût de la non réforme
parce que l'idée c'est que c'est Junker
qui dirigeait. Attendez, je réponds je
réponds d'abord à votre question. Junker
disait on sait ce qu'il faut faire mais
on sait pas comment être élu une fois
qu'on l'a fait. Et
là c'est retraité montre que le coût
politique de la non réforme aujourd'hui
en France est supérieur au coût de la
réforme. C'est comme ça que le président
Macron a perdu la moitié de son
business. Donc question très
pragmatique. Quand vous allez être vieux
et grab à terre à vous pisser dessus, à
vous faire pipi dessus, à plus pouvoir
aller aux toilette tout seul, à pu
pouvoir manger, à lever votre bras pour
ouvrir un placard que vous allez perdre
en autonomie ? Oui.
Vous avez anticipé ça votre femme ? Oui.
Alors, j'icipe, ça existe en Suisse, ça
existe pas encore en France, mais je
pense qu'à à mon époque, si je suis
encore, ça existera. Un système qui
s'appelle Exit. H donc, vous cotisez
combien par mois ? Je n'ai pas de
retraite. J'ai jamais je n'ai jamais
cotisé une retraite par que je n'ai que
de la retraite par capitalisation. Vous
mettez combien par mois de côté pour
anticiper quand vous vous allez pas
vouloir peser sur vos enfants ? Alors
moi je suis lié. On dit si tu veux avoir
de l'argent devant toi mets l'autre
côté. Et donc vous épargn combien par
mois ? Je n'épargne rien du tout.
J'essaie de gagner ma vie en ayant des
gens qui trouvent que ce que je dis est
très bien. Et puis je vois ce qui reste
à la fin du mois. Ce qui reste à la fin
du mois. Vous le mettez de côté.
Je le mets de côté. Non, j'essaie de le
mettre devant pour que ça progresse.
J'ess d'investir. D'accord. Vous
l'investissez ? Oui. Donc votre part
d'investissement par mois, ça représente
combien à peu près ? C'est absolument
pas fixe parce que je suis entrepreneur.
Je n'ai pas moi je suis pas salarié avec
un truc qui tombe tous les mois. Il y a
des mois où je perds de l'argent.
J'investis, je perds de l'argent. Il y a
des mois où j'en gagne. J'ai entreprise.
Quoi ? Moi, je n'aurai jamais de
retraite parce que le jour vous savez
Kissinger alors je sais pas si votre
est-ce que votre grand-mère était liée à
Kissinger ? Pas du tout. Mais Kissinger
pour ses 100 ans, JP Morgan lui a payé
l'avion à Pékin pour qu'il aille faire
une conférence. Et le journaliste lui a
dit "Mais comment vous avez fait pour
être centenaire ?" Il a dit "C'est hyper
simple, c'est que je me suis jamais
arrêté de travailler parce que j'ai noté
que tous mes copains qui prenaient leur
retraite, ils m'ouraient.
Donc je n'aurai jamais de retraite parce
que le jour où on me dira que les gens
ont marre de m'entendre et que je
raconte n'importe quoi comme là je suis
en train de vous énerver
les vous voyez que ben ce jour-là
j'arrêterai j'irai voir Exit et je dirai
bah on ferme. C'estàdire Exit c'estàdire
vous éteignez la lumière. Alors, existe
la manière dont ça marche en Suisse,
c'est que quand vous êtes en pleine
santé, comme vous allez avec un témoin
chez un notaire et vous dites "Voilà, je
souhaite le jour où je n'ai plus mes
moyens physiques, mentaux, je veux qu'on
me coupe le truc." D'accord ? Et vous
devez retourner là, je suis pas en train
de vous parler. Vous devez retourner une
seconde fois avec le même témoin. On y
va. Donc là, je suis pas en train de de
de vous dire que vous allez perdre la
tête, mais quand on va vous mettre une
prothèse de hanche, que vous allez
cludiquer, que vous allez avoir de
l'arthrose aux épaules, que votre main
vous allez avoir une maladie qui va vous
faire une rétractation des tendons et je
vous passe. Ben regardez, grand mascille
103 ans pète la forme, elle pète pas la
forme, elle arqu
mais elle a toute sa tête. Voilà. Mais
elle a elle a du mal à harquer. Oui.
Comment vous allez expliquer à un
agriculteur qui s'est défoncé pour 450
balles par mois toute sa vie à ce qu'
fait euh du pesticide à pas pouvoir
arquer à pas alors qu'il nourrit la
France que sa femme la pension de
reversion ça va être très très compliqué
dans l'état actuel des choses.
Le le système de retraite par
répartition pour eux ça va être
compliqué. Et la retraite d'un
agriculteur c'est pas 25 % d'épargne.
Ouais. Donc on fait comment là ? Alors
on appelle
l'inwin c'est c'est l'homme qui a
construit
Singapour. C'est lui qui a fait Alors en
c'est très marrant parce que en Asie
c'est l'homme le plus respecté du 20e
siècle. Tous les chefs d'état le
consultaient.
En Occident, il est dénoncé comme un
dictateur et je vous recommande son
livre. Alors, je sais plus comment ça
s'appelle. C'est The Great Masters View
on the US, China, Europe and the rest.
Un truc comme ça. Discussion à 90 ans
avec un professeur du MIT, un professeur
d'Arvab. Vous avez 5 pages sur chaque
région du monde extrêmement concise. Et
on lui dit que pensez-vous de l'Europe ?
Il dit l'Europe c'est foutue.
Non, en une phrase, il dit ils ont
remplacé la famille par l'État.
point.
Donc votre
agriculteur effectivement ce qu' a fait
l'État avec lui, c'est scandaleux parce
qu'il est scandaleux qu'un agriculteur
qui bosse comme un dingue gagne entre
350 et 450 € par mois. C'est la vie. Et
ben ce que vous avez, c'est que vous
avez une famille autour de vous et c'est
ça. Et donc arrêtons c'est John Ky,
arrêtons de nous demander ce que l'État
peut faire pour nous et demandons-nous
ce que nous pouvons faire pour l'État.
Ça va être ça la solution. Et donc la
solution c'est que cet agriculteur, il a
un cousin qui a réussi dans la vie, qui
est à la ville et qui dit "Bah je
regarde mais moi j'ai une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de toute la famille et les
familles, ça toujours été comme ça. Le
cousin qui est dans la merde et ben moi
j'ai réussi, je l'aide." Et ça c'est
Chinois. Les chinois, le nouvel an
chinois, ça dure une semaine. Ils ont ce
qu'on appelle des enveloppes rouges dans
lequel ils mettent des
biftons et toute la famille pendant
alors vous allez voir tous les cousins
ça dure une semaine. On résout tous les
problèmes matériels de la famille parce
que celui qui a réussi s'occupe des
fallanges. OK, j'ai compris. Mais nous
en Europe en France là, je vais vous
faire une petite un petit parallèle.
Vous avez déjà piloté un avion ? Non
mais je suis monté dans pas mal d'avions
dans ma vie. D'accord. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand il y a un problème de
portance ?
Ça décroche.
Oui. C'est quoi le problème de portance
? C'est que vous n'êtes c'està-dire
qu'on va pas suffisamment assez vite et
que les ailes elles sont trop petite
pour pouvoir sustenter l'avion et il y a
plus l'espèce d'aspiration au-dessus de
l'aile et donc là on décroche et on
tombe. Oui. Si on reprend de la vitesse
à la ressource, on est content, on on
plane. Donc là en France, on va avoir un
trou d'air, un problème de portance très
vraisemblablement. D'accord. Et donc on
gère comment selon vous ce problème de
portance ? avec le FMI, les vutour au
cul, avec des États qui ont décidé de
nous dépesser comme la Chine et les
États-Unis pour se gagner du temps pour
potentiellement se mettre sur la figure
un peu plus tard ou se répètre de notre
charogne, de nos industries, de tout ce
qu'on va sacrifier pour gagner du temps
au nos politiques, à nos politiques pour
que il puisse passer encore des années
de bombance.
On fait quoi là concrètement avec votre
comité des SE ? Ils vont faire quoi ?
C'estàd quand vous avez un énorme bateau
avec un tout petit tout petit gouvernail
et qu'il y a que des petits requins tout
partout avec des gros iceberg tout
partout et que on est à fond les ballons
avec de la dette pour masquer la réalité
de la situation pour dire que on est le
président du pouvoir d'achat ou je suis
le président magnifique et c'est
extraordinaire je vais sauver la France
et en fait non mais on fait quoi là avec
nos tout petit tout petit gouvernail
alors reprenez du prosac Et je vous ai
déjà dit que les Jeux Olympiques
Notredame ont champion du monde. 7 on
fait sauter toutes les normes. On fout
on fout les vieux au boulot. Euh et puis
s'ils sont plus aptes, on leur fait une
petite piqure. Non, on va trouver un
modus. On va retrouver c'est Johnny, on
va retrouver envie d'avoir
envie. Et c'est comme ça qu'on va
fédérer des gens. Mais on va les fédérer
quand vous avez cette personne. Lisez
Bernard Atali. Vous avez lu Bernard
Atali. Ils ont rebâti la France.
D'accord. Fabuleux. C'est un c'est une
quarantaine de portraits de français en
1945. Moi, j'en connaissais sur les 45,
j'en connaissais quatre cinq qu'on
reconstruit de zéro l'administration
française en 1945. OK. Ils ont été
oubliés de l'histoire. On charge
inercielle, ça vous parle. Donc moi, je
suis très optimiste de nature, hein.
C'est pour ça que je suis investisseur.
Pour être investisseur, faut croire dans
le futur. Donc je pense que c'est juste
une combien de temps que vous perdez de
l'argent là ?
Ah euh depuis que j'investis parce que
tous les jours j'investis en bourse, ça
bouge tous les jours et tous les jours
il y a une position sur laquelle je
perds de l'argent. Quel est votre clé de
lecture en bourse ?
Clé de lecture à propos de quoi ? Bah
c'est vert vert ça monte, rouge ça
baisse. D'accord. Binaire. Oui. Quelle
est votre clé de lecture sur la
géopolitique sur les sociétés ?
lesergie, les matières premières, les
fondamentaux de de sustentation d'une
société
thermoindustrielle. C'est aujourd'hui en
économie de guerre, je vous l'ai dit, je
vous l'ai dit au début, c'est le goulot
d'étranglement. Donc ce que je veux ce
que je veux là, je pense que sur le plan
économique nous sommes partis pour euh
c'est la période 7580 parce qu'il nous
arrive ce qui est arrivé en 71 quand le
dollar a décroché
du de l'or. Nous allons avoir c'est le
pire scénario économique, ça s'appelle
la stackflation. C'est-à-dire que vous
avez une inflation de tous vos coûts et
vous avez un consommateur à qui on a dit
tiens ben tu vois comme on doit
désendetter l'État les 2000 € par mois
que tu avais en moyenne euh ben il y
avait 1000 € de prestation sociale qui
faisait que tu pouvais t'en sortir. Les
1000 € de prestation sociale ils vont
faire ça. Donc votre client qui avait
100 maintenant il va avoir 90 80 et tous
vos coûts augmentent. Donc vos marges y
passent. C'est ce qui est arrivé en 75
80. C'est arrivé alors c'est arrivé à
mes parents juste avant juste par que
vous compreniez ce qui nous arrive.
C'est quoi jusqu'avant juste avant 75 ?
On a eu quoi choc ? Ben c'est le choc
pétrolier qui a fait que mes parents ont
perdu leur pouvoir d'achat. Donc mes
parents ont construit de 1945 à 1975
pendant 30 ans les 30 glorieux des 30
glorieuses, ils ont construit leur
pouvoir d'éch qu'ils ont perdu à travers
une crise énergétique. Là nous avons une
crise géopolitique qui fait que nous
allons être obligés, il va y avoir un
decoupling, il faudra quand même qu'on
en parle à un moment entre parce que
c'est un truc de taré qui devait jamais
arriver entre les États-Unis.
Mais non parce que vous allez voir qu'on
va s'en sortir et qui fait que tous les
coûts vont augmenter parce que ça fait
ça fait 20 ans qu'on bosse à baisser les
coûts en allant partout dans le monde et
là il nous a on va défaire dans les
trois prochaines années ce qu'on a
construit pendant 20 ans en remontant
les coûts partout. Donc ce que nous
allons perdre c'est pas notre pouvoir
d'achat parce que le pouvoir d'achat on
en a pas depuis 20 ans. Les salaires
réels sont stables. Ce que nous en
perdre c'est notre style de vie. C'est
ce que j'appelle la fin des 30
glandeuses. C'està-dire que le style ce
pourquoi nous sommes battus depuis 20
ans, c'est pas des augmentations de
salaires.
C'est la 5e semaine de congé payé, ce
sont les 35 heures, ce sont les RTT, ce
sont les le télétravail où je viens
seulement un jour par semaine au bureau.
Et c'est ça ce pourquoi on se bat depuis
20 ans. Et ça va péter. Donc ce qui va
péter, c'est notre style de vie et on va
se remettre au travail. Je vous
recommande le j'ai fait un plateau de
télé la semaine dernière avec le
secrétaire du parti communiste qui écrit
un bou qui vient très bon manteau sur
l'énergie d'ailleurs les communistes on
les félicite mais il est fabuleux il dit
il dit il faut au boulot et il compris
le nucléaire il dit les gars le
nucléaire on se remet au boulot et je
lui dis mais c'est dire on est on est
pleinement en accord moi je veux être
communiste. Il veut remettre la France
au
travail et on aura du nucléaire
inchallah.
Ça va prendre un peu de temps ça va
prendre un peu de temps. On en est où
avec les réserves d'uranium ? Alors le
bah je sais pas combien on en a parce
que ça enfin ça vous savez peut-être
mais je pense qu'on a suffisamment
d'années pour se retourner. On a un
petit problème avec les Kazakhstan, un
petit problème avec les Niger mais
attends c'est c'est intéressant que vous
nous expliquiez le petit problème avec
le Kazakhstan et le petit problème avec
le Kazakhstan, vous avez des problèmes à
délivrer, c'est ça ? Bah vous avez des
Russes et des alors ils ont un peu de
problèmes de production puis vous avez
des des Russes et des Chinois qui dit "À
venir sera tout pour nous". Bon, donc
euh ça fait euh ça fait désordre. Ça
fait désordre et c'est pour ça que bah
quand vous êtes américain euh la Russie
vous dit le l'uranium enrichi euh est-ce
que où est-ce que ça se trouve
exactement ? Donc euh c'est peut-être
pour ça que au courant du contrat entre
les Russes et les Américains concernant
l'uranium. Alors je l'ai pas vu. Non
mais ça doit être sympathique.
Et donc sur le pétrole, on en est où
avec le pétrole ? Alors sur le pétrole,
bah là le truc qui est quand même
assez incroyable, c'est que on parle
potentiellement de pic pétrole en Chine
cette année. Qui vous en a parlé ? Ah
alors euh vous avez par exemple
Bloomberg qui est une je vous rappelle
les gens là que je paye tous les mois
euh
et on vient de savoir au premier
trimestre que pour la première fois la
capacité installée d'énergie
renouvelable en Chine est supérieure à
celle
des fossil fuel. Donc j'oublie toujours,
c'est les énergies fossiles. Jus
dinosaure. Voilà. Exactement.
Donc euh donc on a et le truc qui est
assez extraordinaire, c'est que vous
êtes censé avoir une guerre au
Moyen-Orient où tout est censé péter et
que au lieu d'avoir le pétrole à 150, il
est à 65 dollars. Donc peut-être que le
monde attend une grosse récession. Ah !
Comment vous percevez vous en tant que
investisseur, en tant que
euh peut-être futurologue ? parce qu'il
faut être futurologue pour être
investisseur. Comment vous vous
anticipez, vous analysez les permis que
Trump est a poussé pour l'exploitation
des nodules polymétalliques ?
Euh ben l'idée c'est de c'est le même
truc hein avec les Américains, c'est que
ils vont je crois qu'ils sont en train
de découvrir toutes leur nouvelles
dépendances et que et donc ils ont eu
ils ont une chance incroyable avec le
pétrole et le gaz de chiste durant toute
la décennie 2010. À 65 dollars, ils font
moins les malins. Donc ils disent "OK,
c'est quoi ? Quelles sont nos autres
dépendances ?" et euh ben il découvre
entre autres que euh il va y avoir des
dépendances dans le futur sur le plan
énergétique. Il y a quand même une
transition énergétique à faire. Ils
disent nous ils pensent qu'ils auront un
avantage compétitif en étant les
derniers à l'affaire en disant pour
l'instant il y a pas de modèle
économique donc on les laisse faire leur
truc et qui perdent de l'argent et quand
ça gagnera de l'argent on ira à fond, on
les rattrapera et on aura rien perdu.
Vrai ou faux ? On verra. C'est le choix
stratégique qu'ils font. Comment vous
vous alors Trump investisseur dans
l'immobilier avec la délicatesse que
peuvent avoir les investisseurs dans
l'immobilier ? Comment vous êtes pas de
dénigrement hein sur le j'ai dit
délicatesse. D'accord.
Comment vous analysez le fait que Trump
propose de prendre le Groenland soit de
gré soit de gré ? Soit de GR Oui. de GR
de GR. Comment vous expliquez comment
vous expliquez le fait que ils veulent
que le Canada devienne une province
américaine ? Alors euh là quelle lecture
vous avez de ça ? Je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux. Vous avez plusieurs
lectures. Vous avez une lecture
géopolitique en disant euh avec le
réchauffement climatique, la fonte des
glaces, en fait la voie maritime va euh
être extrêmement importante et donc il
faut qu'il apprenne. Vous avez
l'héritage de Minley dont on parle plus
d'un siècle plus tard. Donc il dit "Bah
Mcinles, c'est le président des
États-Unis qui a ramené des territoires
aux US. Moi si je veux qu'on parle de
Trump dans 100 200 300 ans, c'est
exactement chi avec Taiïwan et deng avec
Hong Kong. He c'est la même chose. Donc
de dire euh et puis il y a que 50000
types, c'est à nous. Alors tout ce que
je lis c'est que sur le plan minerais
c'est n'importe quoi puisque ça coûte
une fortune et il y a absolument pas de
modèle économique. Donc je pense mais là
je suis absolument pas spécial mais
juste mon réflexe c'est dire bah c'est
sa mégalomanie je veux être dans le
livre d'histoire dans 100 ans et dans
200 ans. Comment vous expliquez le
conflit ukrainien ?
Alors le conflit ukrainien
euh bah moi je l'explique par la poignée
de main. C'est Poutine interview de
Liverstone. la poignée de main entre
Gorbatchov et
Gencher où en 1990 quand on remet
l'Allemagne
ensemble, Gencher Sine sert la main de
Gorbatchov en disant le temps n'ira pas
au-delà de à l'est de
l'Allemagne et comme c'est les
Allemands, ils sont des types OK on peut
confiance, il y a pas de contrat et vous
avez et donc naturellement on n
absolument pas respecté le l'engagement
verbal qui avait été pris. C'est très
intéressant si vous lisez il y a ce
qu'on appelle le lunch with EFT. Donc
dans le Funcial Times, vous avez tous
les samedis le déjeuner avec une
personnalité. Vous avez il y a un mois,
il y a quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas du
tout en France qui a le ministre
d'affaires étrangères indien qui a
depuis une bonne vingtaine d'années et
il dit il a une phrase extraordinaire au
milieu de l'interview. Il dit le concept
de traité appartient à l'ancien monde.
Il n'y a plus d'obligation
juridique. Le monde est un club. On se
rencontre et on discute d'intérêt. Donc
la période de chaos dans laquelle vous
savez quand on est en train de dire les
États-Unis sont en train de tuer l'état
de droit et cetera machin, ça va être le
chaos total. Les Chinois et les Indiens,
ils ont toujours fait ça tous les jours.
Donc pour eux, c'est business as us.
Vous az déjà été en Inde ? J'ai déjà été
en Inde. Oui. Combien de temps ? Alors,
pas longtemps. Temps le temps d'une
petite tourista ou le temps d' Alors,
non parce que je faisais gaffe mais j'y
suis allé deux trois fois mais c'était
juste de tr jours. C'était des quelle
ville ? Euh, Bombay. Bombaï. Oui. Vous
avez fait Varansi, vous avez fait des
d'autres villes comme ça ? Non non,
c'était c juste pour des réunions
d'investisseurs. Donc j'ai fait
Ouais et cetera machin. Donc non, je
vous verrez dans mon livre, il y a trois
pages sur l'Inde qui où je suis très
très négatif parce que je défends
naturellement je suis vendu au Chinois.
Donc j'ai dit que l'Inde ne se décollera
jamais contre par rapport aux Chinois et
en fait je pense que l'Inde va se
décoller. Donc là, c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux qu'on ne le croit et notamment
il y a beaucoup de choses ont changé
dans les 12 derniers mois mais avec un
modèle écomique totalement différent, ça
va pas être du manufacturing
comme en Chine, ça va être les services
à faible valeur ajoutée qui vont servir
à l'industrie. Si s'ils se mettent pas
sur la figure avec les Pakistanais,
hein. Alors, ils se mettront mais vous
en avez un nucléaire
quoi l'Inde et le Pakistan,
quoi. Est-ce qu'ils vont se balancer des
trucs ? Ça je peux pas vous dire mais le
nucléaire c'est de la dissuasion quand
même. Oui, ça dépend ça dépend quelle
quelle
doctrine. Si vous aviez en tant
qu'expathe, si vous vouliez donner un
conseil à un jeune pour s'expatrier,
vous lui conseilleriez quel pays à
l'heure actuelle ? Alors euh si ça ne
sort pas de cette pièce hein, ça reste
entre nous. Euh 2000 personnes en ligne.
Tiens, montre-moi. Euh naturellement
Hong Kong, meilleur endroit du monde. Et
c'est ça coûte combien de location euh à
Hong Kong ? Alors, tout dépend de les
nouveaux apparts, c'est 28 m², donc euh
ça coûte un peu moins cher, mais en gros
pour se loger un l'appartement d'une
chambre, vous en avez pour un bon 2000
2500 € par mois.
D'accord. Le prix du MWAW là-bas, c'est
combien ? Alors ça je peux pas vous le
dire parce que c'est toujours le même
truc. L'eau et l'électricité qui sont
les trucs les plus importants au monde.
On m'a jamais on me je ne me suis jamais
rendu compte de combien je payais. C'est
pour ça que on traite pas le problème.
Combien coûte un ticket de métro à Paris
? Ah alors moi je les achète par euh
carnet de 9 et je paye 29 € donc j'ai
pas de rédu. Le prix du kilo de bœuf ou
alors ça dépend celui que vous voulez.
Vou du Non non mais attendez, vous
voulez du wagou bef japonais là vous en
avez pour là je vous le fais à 300 400 €
le kilo hein sans problème. Vous avez
chez Carrefour au bout de 20 ans de
value for monnaie en fait c'est de la
viande de cheval. Ouais mais bien sûr.
Et donc quand vous quand vous dites
quand vous dites le pouvoir d'achat
n'augmente pas et on est en déflation
faut baisser les coûts. Baisser les
coûts, bah il y a un jour où
malheureusement le type qui vous fait le
bœuf il dit je peux pas. Donc vous avez
des scandales alimentaires où vous
achetez des trucs qui sont donc le ton
est bourré de saloperie. Vous avez vu
que le perrier, les bulles sont bourré
de saloperie. Donc euh appelez appelez
grandma en appelez grand mask. Il y a en
1950 1960 que ma grand-mère elle a un
fusil hein. Donc arrêtez de la faire
référence. Ah ben elle vient avec son
fusil. Madalton j'adore, j'ai énormément
de respect. Elle dépensait 30 % de ses
revenus
en en alimentation, 10 % pour se loger
aujourd'hui. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi il est
305 € ? C'est parce que de nos moins de
30 ans, c'est parce que sur les 2000 qui
gagnent, ils sont obligés d'en mettre
1000 en loyer
pour être dans un 28 m².
Pour être sans doute dans un 40 à 50 m².
Vos enfants ils font quoi ?
Alors, je suis célibataire, j'ai pas
d'enfants mais j'ai neuf fillules. Vous
avez des chats qui sont J'ai pas de
chat. J'ai neuf filloles qui ne cessent
de m'éduquer. Donc comment je suis
informé ? Ben entre autres, j'ai neuf
indiques un peu partout dans le monde
qui me Question Internet. Vous vivez à
Hong Kong, que m que manquet-il aux
Européens pour lire correctement
l'opinion chinoise ? Quels indicateurs
alternatifs suivez-vous au-delà du PIB ?
Euh alors euh à Hong Kong, comment je
fais pour être informé ? C'est à Hong
Kong.
Hong Kong, juste pour vous expliquer à
quel point c'est extraordinaire, c'est
d'abord du point de vue style de vie,
c'est le seul endroit au monde où vous
avez Goldman Sax et à 20 minutes la mer
et la montagne. D'accord ? Donc je vais
dans le quartier financier la journée
m'informer. Le soir, je rentre chez moi,
je vais à la plage ou en montagne pour
respirer et
comprendre. Comment je m'informe ? Je
rencontre des Chinois à qui je demande
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis et je
rencontre des
Américains à qui je demande ce qui se
passe en Chine. Vous un truc très
particulier, c'est que dans cette
seconde guerre froide qui est entre
Chine et Amérique, le seul endroit où
ils peuvent se rencontrer, le seul
endroit au monde où la Chine Amérique
peut se rencontrer, c'est Hong Kong.
Parce que on ne se rend pas compte en
France mais il y a une loi de sécurité
des données qui est passée en Chine. Si
vous sortez de Chine avec une donnée
sensible, sensible n'est pas défini,
quand vous revenez, je peux vous mettre
en prison à vie. Hong Kongque, c'est la
Chine. Donc un Chinois qui vient
négocier un JV à Paris avec son business
plan, potentiellement c'est une
information sensible Chino donc il dit
c'est à Hong Kong. Les Américains ont vu
pendant le Covid que leur équipe a été
enfermée 2 mois à Shangï sans bouffer.
Ils ont failli crever. Ils disent "On y
va pas." Le seul endroit, c'est Hong
Kong. Mais et c'est quoi cette histoire
qu'ils ont failli crever ? Ben, il y a
eu un truc qui s'appelait Covid, je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez. Et à Shangï
qui n'obéissait pas vraiment à Pékin,
bah les Changaillers ont été enfermés
pendant 2 mois sans pouvoir sortir de
chez eux. Il n'avait pas de la
nourriture tous les jours comme ça c'est
fait du jour au lendemain au début il y
avait pas de
nourriture pas les bons petits plats de
grand maskaille euh la
ratatouille ça va le faire
marrer. On parle de résilience on parle
de robustesse. Est-ce que vous avez vu
Emmanuel Macron copier le modèle suédois
avec ce petit fasicule en cas de tempête
de guerre de catastrophe. Il faut avoir
sa petite radio, sa couverture de
survie, des photocopies de papier
identité, de la flotte et j'en passer
des meilleurs. Vous vous voyez ça
comment ? En tant qu'investisseur, en
tant que gestionnaire ? Ben nous, c'est
exactement l'inverse. C'est-à-dire qu'on
fait 6 % de le drame, c'est qu'on fait 6
% de déficit
budellement une
demande et on ne fait aucun déficit pour
la production.
Donc le problème c'est que nos retraites
c'est 14 % du PNB, c'est 7 % en
accident. Vous avez vu le ficule de Non
pardon le fascicule je l'ai pas eu. Mais
vous me demandez si le président Macron
poursuit une économie une politique
d'économie de guerre et je vous dis non
c'est il n'a toujours pas compris il
continue à faire l'ultime politique
d'économie de paix qui consiste à
soutenir artificiellement une demande
alors qu'on ne produit plus et que donc
forcément on doit acheter chez les
autres. Et c'est pour ça qu'on finit
avec 100 milliards de déficit
commercial. Et je me suis fait incendier
sur un plateau de télévision la semaine
dernière parce que j'ai dit la
désindustrialisation c'est un choix du
politique. C'est pas du tout un choix
des entreprises et c'est vraiment une
règle de base. C'est que quand vous
quand vous désindustrialisez qu'est-ce
que vous faites ? Notre industrie est
passée de 20 % du PNB à 10 % l'espace de
20 ans. C'est qui s'est gavé entre les
deux ? Vous attendez, non, vous perdez
bah qui s gavé sur les politiques
puisque vous perdez 10 % de vos
électeurs qui sont licenciés, mais vous
gagnez 90 % qui ont un gain de pouvoir
d'achat. Prenez Shine et Temu, ça vous
dit quelque chose ? Vous connaissez ?
Les Chinois qui cher et et des petits
colis. Voilà. Exactement. Taxé. Euh,
ouais, mais jusqu'à présent, c'est 22 %
des volumes de la Poste. Ça appartient à
qui la
poste. Donc l'État se goinfre. L'État
c'est nous. Ouais. Extrêmement heureux
de se faire un max de fric avec la POE
qui est soudainement a 22 % de volume
supplémentaire et vous avez la famille
Mullier entrepreneuse depuis dans le
nord de la France depuis deux trois
générations dont tous les business de
distribution non alimentaire ferment les
uns après les autres. C'est ça les
autres 7 points et demi que Macron a
perdu entre 2022 et 2024. Je comprends
le raison. Donc le monsieur Trump qui a
tous les défauts de la terre, il est
arrivé dit executive order, il y a pas
un colis qui rentre demain. Nous mon
Parlement européen qui était vide quand
je suis allé, ils ont dit "Oui, on s'en
occupera en
2028." Bon ben en 2028, il y a plus un
une magasin de distribution non
alimentaire quand vous avez Shine et TMU
qui vendent à perte. Et c'est la
technique chinoise, on la connaît. C'est
ça le second choc chinois. Le premier
choc chinois c'est 2001. La Chine rentre
dans l'EMC, elle fait ce qu'on ne veut
plus faire, elle fait les trucs à basse
valeur ajoutée, elle fait les trucs qui
polluent. C'est comme ça que nous les
comme ça qu'on met une laisse à un pays.
Non, pardon. C'est comme ça qu'on met
une laisse à un pays. Ben c'est comme ça
qu'on a été hyper bon. On a dit les CO2,
on en fait 7 % dans le monde, ils en
font 30. Donc là, donc on les tient.
Donc vous allez dire on va taxer parce
que bon OK, j'ai
compris. Comment vous voyez vous en tant
que business angel ? Alors, je suis
business démon, hein, mais c'est comme
ça qu' on me surnomme, mais fondateur de
Non, je suis pas Angel.
Comment vous voyez la le concept de
Start-up Nation, l'élevage de la licorne
sacrée ? Alors, euh, on est quand même
les seuls au monde à dire qu'on a un
pays tech.
Donc vous savez, c'est génial quand il y
a le CIS à Las Vegas, on arrive
toujours, on dit "Mais c'est fabuleux,
il y a que la France qui a son stand
French, on est vraiment les meilleurs au
monde." Bien évidemment parce que tous
les autres pays savent que la tech par
définition n'a pas de frontière. Quand
vous faites une boîte de tech
aujourd'hui de digital par définition,
vous ne la faites
pas pour votre pays, vous la faites pour
l'ensemble de la planète. Donc il n'y a
que nous qui pensons que la tech doit
être nationale.
En terme de souveraineté technologique.
La souveraineté, ça n'existe pas. Nous
sommes en interdépendance, vous ne serez
jamais Si vous êtes souverain, vous
allez à la fate garantie. Pourquoi ? Ben
parce que le monde si vous faites un
truc qui est un peu intelligent, je sais
bien, alors là on va passer de l'autre
côté, c'est que je vous ai dit que la
France était absolument géniale quand
elle faisait Notre Dame et mais on n pas
non plus le monopole de toutes les idées
géniales du monde. Et donc quand vous
faites quelque chose de très compliqué,
mettons par exemple des semi-conducteurs
d'autres
technologies, il n'y a pas un pays qui
fait qui fasse tout. Je disais hier les
IRM qu'on a dans nos hôpitaux, il y a
235 pièces différentes assemblées qui
viennent de 15 pays. Quand Trump taxe
ça, il y a des pièces qui viennent des
US, il y a des pièces qui viennent de
Chine. La Chine dit "Je ne m'en achète
pas si vous avez une pièce américaine."
Les États-Unis disent "Si vous avez une
pièce chinoise, je vous taxe à 150 %."
Fait comment ? Vous vous rappelez de la
guerre en Irak ? Alors euh laquelle ? La
première 1990, je cherchais un job. Il y
avait premier job que j'ai cherché, il y
avait pas un job à Paris. Donc je m'en
souviens tout à fait. J'étais au
chômage. Vous vous rappelez l'histoire
des French fries et des Freedom Fries ?
Ouais, les absolument. Est-ce que vous
vous rappelez aussi de l'histoire de
notre catapulte sur Porte-avion ? Alors
là par contre, il faut rafraîchir ma
mémoire.
On va dire que
comme on avait eu après à la
deuxè un ministre des affaires
étrangères doublé d'un d'un corn à cœur
de discours qui avait dit nous la France
d'un vieux continent là on connaît ce
que c'est la guerre vous vous rappelez
pas de dénigrement pas de dénigrement et
derrière on avait les États-Unis qui
débaptisaient les frites Ouais et qui
nous disait bon maintenant tu as
catapulte de porteavion, il y a une
petite pièce américaine dedans. Bah et
on a gagné, on a gagné. C'est nous, on a
été les meilleurs.
Discours de 2003. Et le côté souverain
de la technologie, c'est peut-être bien,
non ?
Euh c'est illusoire.
C'est ce que les États-Unis vont
découvrir. Là, ce qui se passe depuis,
il faut peut-être qu'on passe 3 minutes,
faut peut-être qu'on on passe 2 minutes
sur ce qui se passe depuis 10 jours
parce que c'est
potentiellement vraiment une cassure
totale et je mets ça au conditionnel
parce qu'en 10 jours, je ne prétends pas
avoir
compris. Les États-Unis, il va y avoir
potentiellement quelque chose que depuis
3 ans, je dis que c'est impossible. Ça
n'arrivera jamais parce que ce sera une
telle catastrophe que c'est
le
découplage le découplage entre les
États-Unis et la
Chine et donc vous avez Trump qui a vous
avez suivi qui a mis tous ces et la
technique américaine c'est The Zart of
the deal. Je demande un truc
complètement débile et je reviens à la
table de négociation, je baisse et en
fait j'ai un deal bien meilleur parce
que je vous ai mis l'encre beaucoup
trop. Est-ce que quand vous êtes allé en
Chine, est-ce que vous a raconté
l'histoire du permis de conduire ?
Comment on passe son permis de conduire
en Chine ? Jamais été en Chine. C'est
pas jamais été en Chine. On nous a
proposé plusieurs fois là-bas. Génial.
Donc euh si vous passez votre permis de
conduire en Chine, l'examinateur va vous
dire "Monsieur Sky, est-ce que vous avez
déjà conduit ?" Bah une moissonneuse
batteuse ? Alors vous répondez bah non,
j'ai pas comme j'ai pas le permis, je
n'ai pas conduit. Et donc l'inspecteur
vous dit "Et ben donc ça veut dire que
vous ne savez pas conduire. Vous êtes un
danger public donc je vous fais pas le
permis. Au revoir
monsieur. Donc vous revenez un peu plus
tard et vous dites "Bah avec Grand
Maskaille, elle m'a fait faire 1000
bornes dans sa voiture en conduite
accompagné. Donc donc là l'inspecteur
dit "Ah bah très bien, vous avez fait 1
B, vous savez conduire donc je vous
donne le permis." Et j'écris à la main
PS sur le permis a conduit 1000 heures
avant son permis.
Ce qui fait que chaque fois chaque fois
que vous êtes arrêté par un flic, il
peut vous mettre en
t et donc quand les États-Unis
reviennent en disant on va passer de 150
% à 10 % on va ramener à 10 % parce que
ça ou 50 ou vous avez vu Apple il y a 3
jours. Apple a dit je déménage 60
millions d'iPhone en Inde d'ici fin
2026. Alors, je suis pas au courant des
derniers îles, ils étaient de 40 %. Euh,
Foxconc en Chine, avec du gaz russe.
Ouais, Foxconc 99,9 %. Donc, qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? C'est que pour les
industriels présents en Chine pour
exporter aux US, il se moquent de savoir
si on va être à 150, à 40, à 10. C'est
que le président Trump a créé une
telle insécurité, instabilité que, comme
dit un industriel, il a dit "Mes usines,
elles sont pas sur roulette."
Donc de toute façon, je prends
aujourd'hui la décision que je ne
fabriquerai plus en Chine pour exporter
aux US. Donc la Chine est totalement
indépendante dans le futur. Elle passera
par le Vietnam, elle passera par Mexico,
on verra. Mais il n'y aura plus de par
contre la Chine, vous savez ce que je
vous ai dit au début 2017, ça fait 8 ans
qu'il
bosse sur des
découplages. Et donc on narrête pas de
nous parler des terres rares machin, ça
va être mais les terres rares, enfin
faut être débile mental si on est
dépendant des terres rares. Tout le
monde sait que un elles sont pas rares
et que deuxièmement comme ça coûte c'est
micromarchés c'est des marchés qui sont
en dizaines de millions d'US centaines
de millions d'US. Donc si vous n'avez
pas stocké, c'est comme votre question
sur l'uranium chez Urano. Si Orano n'a
pas stocké, je sais pas si c'est 5, 10,
15, 20 années d'uranium alors que au
Kazakhstan et au Niga, il y a un
problème, ben c'est qu'ils savent pas
vraiment gérer la boîte. Et donc le vrai
danger, il est pas là. Le vrai danger,
c'est le second choc chinois. C'est le
fait que comme je vous ai dit, le
Boeing, la porte, elle tient avec un
boulon et le boulon, il est très
spécial.
C'est un boulon italien et que le boulon
alors je dis le boulon je sais pas ce
que c'est mais dans un boing il y a
forcément un truc que les Chinois font
avec une part de marché mondial de 90 %
et qui vaut 10 dollars. Donc Boeing s'en
est jamais occupé et ils vont dire pour
10 dollars on arrête un Boeing de 200
millions et ça vous allez l'avoir
surtout. Et alors sur le gâteau toutes
ces discussions qu'on a sur les tarifs
elles portent sur les biens
manufacturés. C'est 20 % de l'économie.
l'économie américaine 70 % c'est des
services. Donc tous les calculs
macroéconomiques qu'on fait en disant
l'économie américaine ne va être impacté
qu'à hauteur de 1,5 % parce que c'est
juste les 20 % qui sont
atteints. La grande tendance du de la
technologie c'est la fusion du hardware
et du software parce que l'intelligence
va ce qu'on appelle de edge et que elle
fusionne avec si vous avez pas le
capteur pour avoir le logiciel que vous
voulez. Si vous avez pas le bon capteur
ça marchera pas. C'est ce que fait la
Chine
depuis 2017 où
défonce les Américain. Donc ce qu'on va
découvrir ce que et c'est pour ça que
chi vous avez vu que Trump il a dit à 3
jours j'ai eu chi au téléphone ça va
très bien ça va très bien se passer et
les Chinois ont répondu il y a jamais eu
de col donc en fait les Américains
toujours la même chose dans le business
si vous êtes arrogant vous paumez tout
les Américains de les Américains de par
leur arrogance vont découvrir que les
Chinois bossent depuis 8 ans sur le
dossier descoupling autosuffisance et là
où c'est Très là, je vais vous faire
plaisir avec toutes vos questions
énergétiques, c'est que
Taïwan, Taïwan quand on est en Asie,
tout le monde s'accorde sur le fait que
il y aura jamais d'intervention
militaire. C'est impossible à faire.
Tout le monde tout le monde n'importe
quelle vous demandez à n'importe qui
dans la rue et vous allez à Taïwan parce
une semaine à Taïwan
rencontrainte. Leur crainte c'est le
blocus énergétique. Il y a 15 jours de
gaz naturel liquéfié. Il y a 90 gens de
pétrole et nous on a toujours répondu,
les Chinois peuvent pas le faire parce
que si ils le font, on leur impose un
blocus économique et ils crèveront. Et
président Chichi, qu'est-ce qu'il est en
train d'imposer à sa population
aujourd'hui ? Il dit "En fait,
j'organise le blocus économique parce
que les US on est en guerre avec les
US." Et donc vous avez 1.4 milliards de
Chinois qui disent "Mais
moi pour battre les US mais je suis prêt
à tout." Donc là, vous me parliez de les
salaires de salaires qui baissent, mais
l'an dernier, les salaires ont baissé en
Chine, c'est jamais arrivé. Donc
préparation à l'économie de guerre.
Exactement. Donc, on va rentrer en
économie de guerre.
Ben nous on va on a on est on est un
petit peu dirigé par la bande de de de
de touristes. Alors nous voyez prenez
une capacité de
d'anticipation aussi pertinente qu'une
colopathie fonctionnelle chez un gamin
de 4 ans ? Pas de dénigrement. Non mais
c'est pas c'est c'est c'est quand vous
êtes pas capable de faire un budget avec
les recettes et les rentrées alors que
vous avez un ministère. Oui, c'est pas
mal. Non mais le contrat de gestion un
chat. Ouais. et qu'en plus vous dites
"Bah j'ai trouvé la solution, je vais
nommer neuf macroéconomistes qui vont
m'aider à faire du contrôle de gestion."
Non mais c'est connector, je suis
d'accord. Donc là ça devient compliqué
quand même quand nous en France alors
comment on va faire ? Bah prenons
exemple sur l'Allemagne trois
dépendances gaz russe défense américaine
exportation chinoise et Fré arrive il
dit j'ai une solution au tr et la
solution c'est quoi ? Et la solution
c'est le là comme j'ai 1000 milliards
1000 milliards j'ai une marge de
manœuvre. Donc bah le gaz milliard vont
aller aux États-Unis. Ben le gaz naturel
liquifié à partir de 27 de 27 28g le
Qatar qui arrive avec des productions en
hausse de 60 % donc je vais pouvoir
jouer j'en aurai l'un contre l'autre
donc avec les gazoduc ça pète
facilement. Je vous dis pas que ça va
être gratos hein, mais bon, j'ai une
solution hein. Euh le la défense
américaine, bah je fais le deal de mon
industrie automobile qui va au tapis, je
vais la reconvertir. Je dis à Reine Méal
déjà d'acheter des boîtes américaines
qui seront sous-traitants des trucs que
je vais acheter aux US, donc transfert
de technologie et puis les exportations
chinoises. Je sais que c'est terminé
parce qu'on y reviendra peut-être qu'il
y a pas de consommation chinoise pendant
10 20 ans. Et donc il me reste deux
régions à conquérir qui font plus d'un
milliard de gens. l'Asie du Sud-Est,
l'Azéane et l'Amérique latine. Ça n'a
jamais marché. De même que quand je suis
allé en Allemagne, quand je suis allé en
Chine en 2009, moi Allemagne, tout le
monde a récané en disant tu vas perdre
ta chemise et en fait pendant toute une
décennie, ça a très bien marché. Donc je
sais pas si l'Allemagne va réussir en
marche plus maintenant. Ah ben non, là
c'est foutu. C'est foutu pour une raison
enfin à mon sens pour une raison très
simple, c'est que c'est la première fois
que vous avez une crise immobilière qui
n'est supportée que par sa
population. Donc juste une parler des
gos petite petite
parenthèse la crise immobilière en Chine
c'est 4000 c'est 50 millions
d'appartements vites 30 millions
d'appartements inachevés. Il y en a pour
4000 milliards. JP Morgan estimation
4000 milliards dollars, c'est 20 % du
PNB. Juste une idée, le subprime aux
États-Unis, c'était 10 %. L'Espagne en
2008 cit 10 %. Donc vous avez une crise
qui est deux fois plus importante. Et
quand vous avez le sub prime chez nous,
vous avez les banques qui morfent,
l'IMAN Brothers, vous avez les assureurs
et ID, vous avez
le TARP, le gouvernement qui paye et
vous dites et je mets les taux à zéro.
Et les Américains vous dites vendez pas
votre maison parce que maintenant vos
intérêts sont à zéro et ça va repartir.
Là le gouvernement dit ce sont les
municipalités qu'on fait n'importe quoi.
Pékin dit je ne paye pas. Les banques et
les assureurs appartiennent à l'État,
donc ils ont l'interdiction de soutenir.
Et donc c'est la population, il y a pas
de retraite. Donc vous avez mis 70 % de
vos avoirs qui sont votre retraite dans
l'immobilier qui à Hong Kong on en est à
- 40 et on va on pense atterrir l'an
prochain à - 60. En Chine on est à - 20
et le gouvernement chinois vous dit on a
atteint le bas. Donc il y en a étaler 20
% de perte sur si c'est 10 ans, ça vous
fait 2 % de croissance par an qui
disparaît. Si c'est 20 ans, ce sera 1 %.
Donc vous n'aurez plus jamais de
consommation intérieure en Chine.
Aujourd'hui, les Chinois épargnent 55 %
de leur salaire.
55. Je dis que les vieux nous, ils sont
à 25. Les Français en moyenne, ils sont
aux alentours de 15 et on est parmi aux
US, ils sont plus aux alentours de 8.
Vous vous quel regard vous avez sur les
cryptonnaies ? Bitcoin en particulier.
J'ai cru voir un un avis euh émanu de
2021.
Un avis, c'est-à-dire vous votre vous
aviez donné votre avis en 2021 sur le
Bitcoin. Je je si mes souvenirs sont
bons. Alors là, vous avez plus de
mémoire que moi. Euh alors le Bitcoin,
malheureusement, j'ai les cheveux gris
et ça marche pas. Le Bitcoin, c'est l'or
pour les moins de 30 ans. Alors euh il y
a pas de juste les Émirati, hein. Ouais.
Bon, il y a juste un petit problème,
c'est que vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez
pas de justification par les revenus,
par le cash et vous n'avez pas de
justification par un actif sous-jacent.
Donc voyez, il y a rien. Donc je crois
beaucoup plus au stable coin qui sont
adossés sur le dollar et qui la manière
de c'est quand voit que le dig la photo
digitale arrive, vous avez c'est la
grande technique américaine quand il y a
une disruption et que vous êtes l'acteur
historique, soit vous dites bah non non
ça va pas marcher. Soit vous dites je
vais en fait contrôler la disruption. Et
donc ce que veut faire le gouvernement
américain et la banque fédérale, c'est
contrôler la disruption en disant cette
disruption digitale qui va être très
importante pour euh notamment euh faire
disparaître tout le coût des
transferts financiers, pour faire
disparaître dans le métier que je fais
de la gestion d'actifs, euh tout le
business de custody va disparaître parce
que tout ça va être tokenisé et que donc
vous allez pouvoir réduire les coûts des
services financiers de manière
absolument drastique. Donc un gain de
compétitivité incroyable, mais tout ça
est adossé sur le dollar. Et donc ce que
vous allez faire, c'est quand on dit
qu'il va y avoir une dédolarisation, en
fait il va y avoir une rédolarisation à
travers le stable coin. Question
internet, vous affirmez que l'Europe est
condamnée à devenir un champ de bataille
entre les États-Unis et la Chine. Mais
n'est-ce pas sous-estimer les capacités
d'action, d'innovation et de résilience
du continent européen qui reste le
premier marché mondial et l'un de ses
plus grands réservoirs de matière grise
? Votre analyse ne néglige-t-elle pas
les leviers politiques, économiques et
technologiques dont dispose l'Europe
pour penser activement dans la
recomposition du monde plutôt qu'en
rester une victime passive ? Génial.
Question que j'adore. Euh ah elle est
pas finie, il y en a une un autre. Si
l'Europe est vraiment condamné à la
marginalisation, comment expliquez-vous
sa capacité à rester un leader mondial
dans le dans des domaines comme
l'aéronautique, le luxe ou la transition
écologique ? Ouais.
Alors si vous êtes un jeune chinois,
vous n'avez pas la liberté d'agir
puisque le Congrès de 2022 fait que le
capital privé est désormais sous
contrôle étatique. Si vous avez 25 ans
que vous êtes aux US, vous n'avez plus
la liberté de penser puisque vous avez
le choix entre le wisme et le tropisme.
Le seul endroit au monde, pays développé
où vous avez la liberté de penser et
d'agir, c'est l'Europe. Si vous croyez
si vous croyez à la liberté je votre
auditeur je suis tout à fait en ligne
avec Europe, il y a quoi ? La liberté de
penser. Absolument. Non mais mais c'est
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui, voyez. Enfin,
on va peut-être finir en tô le demain,
je sais pas. Mais si demain je suis j'ai
mon avion demain pour Hong Kong, si je
suis pas arrêté à l'aéroport, c'est que
j'avais encore le droit de m'exprimer
chez vous. Euh donc on a la liberté de
penser et on a la liberté d'agir parce
que si vous voulez créer une boîte, vous
pouvez encore créer une boîte. Il y a un
capital privé qui est respecté.
Donc je suis absolument pas je veux pas
donner l'impression que je suis négatif
pour l' mais je veux pas non plus vous
dire que on va gagner alors comment on
va s'en sortir pourquoi pourquoi on y
arrive pas c'est le rapport Dragy Trump
là on lui en veut parce qu'il nous met
fqu les cons de la Grèce non c'est pas
lui. Non non, c'était Goldmak mais lui
il était je le connaissais à l'époque,
il travaillait chez Gold Matsac, il
s'occupait de l'Italie, il s'occupait
pas de la Grèce donc non euh non non
c'est c'est Schroder et Chirac c'est
Schreer et Shirac qui a fait du window
dressing sur les comptes de la Grèce
pour permettre alors ils étaient
beaucoup mais Goldman était numéro 1 et
c'est surtout c'est 2003 Eurostat arrivé
avec les vrais chiffres ils ont habillé
ils ont maquillé le tapin c'est ça bah
vous avez fait ce qu'on appelle ils ont
maquillé la vieille ouais vous faites ce
qu'on appelle du off balance sheet c'est
que vous sortez des trucs orbiant bon
les Chinois ont fait la même chose sur
l'immobilier donc c'est pour ça que ça
pète aujourd'hui.
Euh mais revenons à l'Europe puisque la
question de cet auditeur est géniale. On
en veut à Trump parce qu'il nous dit "Je
vais vous mettre des tarifs de 20 %."
Mais si vous lisez le rapport Dragy de
l'an dernier qu'on a on a tous dit qu'il
était fantastique mais on a enterré, il
y a pas une décision qui a été prise
depuis, il a expliqué que en matière de
service pan européen, chaque fois que
vous franchissez une frontière, vous
avez un tarif déguisé, donc un droit de
douane de 45 %.
Alors moi quand je vais à Strasbourg la
semaine
dernière, j'en reviens un tout petit peu
déprimé au début dans mon TGV qui me
ramène à Paris en disant non c'est que
je me dis on est à l'époque digitale
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? Je vous
pose une question. Est-ce que déjà dans
votre vie vous avez pris une décision à
27 et chacun avait un droit de véau ? Ça
vous arrivez ou pas ? Bah ça dépend. Non
mais juste est-ce que vous avez une fois
dans votre vie vous étiez 27 autour de
la table, il fallait prendre une
décision et chacun avait un droit de
véau. Est-ce que ça vous est arrivé ?
Sûr que non. Donc ça n'existe pas. Donc
à Bruxelles, ils ont réussi à inventer
un truc qui n'existe pas. Donc et ça
c'est la technique chinoise. Voyez,
c'est pour ça qu'il faut il faut
s'imprégner des Chinois. La Chine a eu
le même problème qu'on a en 90 en
1998 parce que il signait l'OMC en 2001,
donc l'entrée dans l'organisme mondial
du commerce en disant il y a plus de il
va plus y avoir de douanes. Donc les
États-Unis étaient persuadés qu'ils
allaient envahir la Chine parce que les
produits américains étaient super. Et il
y avait le premier ministre de l'époque
Zongi qui est absolument pas connu en
France mais qui en Chine est un vraiment
quelqu'un de vénéré. Il y avait
l'économie était très très largement
faite de boîtes étatiques totalement non
compétitive. EDF GDF mais à la puissance
5000. Et il a dit je vais même pas
essayer de les réformer. Ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais autoriser les
concurrents privés à les concurrencer.
Et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
? Comment on va restructurer les 27
états ? On va créer un 28e état digital.
Et l'énorme avantage, c'est qu'on a une
boîte en France qui s'appelle peut-être
d'asso système sont des types fabuleux
qui font ce qu'on appelle les digital
mockup. Donc ils vous prennent ils vous
prennent par exemple un avion ou une
voiture et il vous la redessinent en
digital de manière à ce que vous
puissiez la reconstruire pour votre
nouveau modèle le faire. Vous gagnez un
temps pas possible parce que avec le
digital vous pouvez modifier en période
et c'est comme ça qu'une voiture qui
mettait 6 ans à venir elles ont
maintenant on les fait en 2 ans, on va
les faire en 12 mois.
Ce 28e
état, c'est là que je vais enregistrer
ma
société et chaque fois que je signe un
contrat, des impôts où la société ?
Alors justement, attendez, chaque fois
que j'ai une relation avec quelqu'un, ça
peut être le fisque, ça peut être un
client, ça peut être un fournisseur, je
vais choisir le pays des 27 de
l'Union qui me est le plus. Donc vous
vous monsieur Sky, je vais vous
embaucher à Paris. Vous allez bosser
pour moi mais je vais le contrat il va
être fait. Je connais pas je suis pas
spécialiste de droit du travail mais en
Estonie mais j' me faire soigner en
Estonie. Non, vous êtes en France et qui
c'est qui va payer le système ? Ah ben
justement, justement ben il va falloir
vous restructurer parce que ce qui va se
passer que comme vous n'êtes pas
compétitif comme si vous foutez rien, il
va falloir que je vous paye je sais pas
quoi 2 3 ans de salaire pour vous virer
alors que vous foutez rien. En Estonie,
j'imagine que on dit bah tu le type qui
était claqué. Ben oui, parce que parce
qu'on bosse. Alors et donc et donc ce
que vous faites c'est que vous créez
cette concurrence entre les États et en
disant vous n'essayez pas de réformer,
c'est pas possible. C'est c'est ce sont
les boîtes étatiques de Chine en 98 et
ce que vous faites c'est que vous vous
faites venir la concurrence des autres
États qui va gagner c'est l'Europe de
l'Est. C'est évident. Vous connaissez la
communication non violente ?
La communication non violente. Je fais
ça tous les jours. Donc ben je suis sans
doute monsieur Jourdin. Je le fais sans
le savoir. C'est ça. Non non pas du
tout. Dites dites-moi
euh ce monde hyper compétitif
non mais il dans l'hyper performance.
Ouais. Qui a créé une hyperconsommation.
J'ai pas terminé. part de qui a créé une
hyperconsommation, une hyperpression sur
le biotope, sur les ressources, sur la
mer, sur l'air et j'en passe et j'en
passe et sur l'énergie.
Donc cet état
d'esprit, vous pensez que ça peut aller
jusqu'à où ?
l'hypercompétitivité, l'hyper
optimisation, l'hyper de machin, l'hyper
l'hyper l'hyper se réformer hyper hyper
hyper hyper pour aller où ? À quel prix
? Comment ?
Quand j'ai eu mon premier job il y a 30
ans, on était 700 millions sur la
planète. 700 combien ? 700 millions il y
a 30 ans. Ouais. Vous êtes sûr de vos
chiffres ? Ouais. Parce que je bossais
dans la finance à Londres et il n'y
avait que des Américains et des
Européens. Et le reste ça existait pas.
Ça existait pas. J'avais pas de
concurrence. Aujourd'hui, c'est 7
milliards 7 à 8 milliards. À Hong Kong,
si je veux embaucher quelqu'un, j'ai le
choix entre des gens qui viennent des
Capc du monde. En 30 ans, le monde a
fait x 10 sur le plan économique.
Arrêtez les on regarde pas le GD, les
PNB, c'est totalement faux. L'économie,
les gens qui sont font partie du système
et c'est le vrai message du Covid. Le
vrai message du Covid, c'est ça pète.
C'est ça le vrai message du Covid. C'est
dire si vous déforestez qu' des trucs
qui se baladent des virus machin, il
prennent de la viande, tac, tout le
monde y passe. Ça va péter. Ça va péter.
Et si vous lisez un peu l'institut
pasteur, il vous dit les gars, la
fréquence à laquelle ça va revenir,
c'est pas ça va pas
être
1920. Donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ben
moi, je crois au cerveau humain et le
cerveau humain va arranger tout ça et
nous allons diviser par 10. Tout le but
du digital, c'est de diviser par 10.
Donc c'est pas le produit qui compte,
c'est la
fonction. Nous allons diviser par 10
pour produire le même but recherché. Je
vous donne un exemple qui j'espère vous
fera un peu marrer. Euh les produits de
luxe en Chine. Vous êtes une jeune
chinoise de 25 ans et vous allez au bar,
vous allez en boîte et vous voulez que
draguer les types qui les Chinois qui
viennent vers vous. Qu'est-ce que vous
faites avant le Covid ? C'est c'est pas
l'inverse vous. Ah oui, c'est vrai qu'il
y a eu
Non, parce que vous voulez Non, vous
Non, les filles, elles veulent de riche.
Il a pas beaucoup de filles, c'est ça en
Chine. Non, vous avez vous
avez vous avez 116 garçons pour 100
fille. Donc moi j'ai je ch mais c'est
génial vous avez un bol monstrueux en
plusieurs forces dit non parce que les
116 il y en a 10 qui sont riches max
donc en fait on est 100 pour 10 voire 5
donc en fait méga concurrentiel c'est
quoi riche en Chine alors bah tout alors
pour nos marchés à
nous l'Oréalyz il y a 100 millions de
chinois font 3000 € par mois 3000 € on
est riche
Ah bah 3000 € oui vous êtes riche en
Chine bien sûr. Oui parce qu'on a ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon
l'ajustement des parités de pouvoirs
d'achat. C'est tout le problème de
militaire hein. C'est que les la Chine
dépense 300 milliards. Les US dépensent
ça fait diff
et c'est ça le problème qu'on a. C'est
pour ça que les militaires ils disent il
faut qu'on passe de 3 % du PNBA 5. Mais
je reviens à ma chinoise. Euh avant le
Covid qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ? Elle va
acheter un sac super classe d'une de nos
marques. Ça coûtait en gros 6000. 6000
dollars. Pendant le Covid, comme tous
les États du monde ont arrosé, nos
marques de luxe, elles ont doublé le
prix. Donc le le sac aujourd'hui, il
veut
12000. Euh la jeune chinoise, elle est
allé voir Grandma Sky en lui disant
"Grandma, est-ce que tu pourrais pas me
filer 6000 US ? Parce que il faut que
j'aille draguer, faut que je ramène un
là, faut que je me marie, hein. Ma
grand-mère grand-mère est hyper sympa.
Elle pas du genre faire ça. Ah ouais !
Oui, ben grandma-ma elle est pas
chinoise. La grand-mainoise.
Et donc aujourd'hui, Grandma a paumé dit
"J'ai 70 % de ma fortune en
immobilier. Euh la jeune chinoise qui
bosse, on lui a dit "Ton salaire c'est
moins 10 % si elle continue à payer."
Donc il y a plus il y a plus le sac à
12000 dollars, je peux plus l'acher.
Donc qu'est-ce que je fais ? Pendant le
Covid, les Chinois ont découvert le
parfum. Ils étaient chez eux, ils se
parfumaient pas, ils ont découvert le
parfum. Et comme il pousse toujours les
trucs beaucoup plus loin, donc ils ont
acheté des parfums, mais il faut que je
sois unique. Donc en fait des ce qu'on
appelle des
kollu sont venus sur internet et ont dit
il y a un truc qui est
démélang tous les mecs craquent et tu
seras la seule à être parfumé comme ça.
Un parfum ça coûte 300 € vous achetez
quatre parfums, c'est 1200 € 1200
dollars. Donc pour 1/10 du prix du sac,
j'ai le même effet. Tous les jeunes
chinois riches sont autour de moi.
Dragué en Chine. Donc je divise donc je
divise par dragé en Chine. Pardon ? Vous
vous faites draguer en Chine ? Non mais
je fais pas draguer. Vous avez vu ma
tête ça risque pas. Non non puis moi je
suis pauvre, je je suis un accidental.
Moi je suis pauvre. Votre portefeuille.
Mais non mais mais non mais si je vous
comprends bien la chinoise sélectionne
en fonction du portefeuille. Ce que je
doute d'ailleurs clairement. Non, non,
mais il y a, je rappelle qu'il y a plus
de milliardaires en Chine qu'aux
États-Unis, hein. Moi je Enfin, arrêtez,
en Chine, on est pauvre nous. Nous nous
et d'ailleurs, quand les Chinois
viennent à Parz moins de 3000 € par
mois, pardon, vous gagnez moins de 3000
€ par mois. Alors, ça dépend. Il y a des
mois où je perds beaucoup d'argent, il y
a des mois où j'en gagne beaucoup. Donc,
une année, ça revient à combien ? Pardon
? Lycée sur une année, ça revient à
combien par mois ? Alors, ça je peux pas
vous dire parce que chaque année est
totalement différente. Je Non, mais
c'est c'est ma vie d'entrepreneur. Si
vous pouvez pas demander à un
entrepreneur combien tu gagnes par mois,
combien tu gagnes par an ? patrimoine ?
Votre patrimoine s'élève à combien ?
Euh, j'ai jamais calculé. Je sais pas.
C'est pas ce qui me c'est pas ce qui me
motive. Vous faitz quoi comme montre ?
Euh, je montrer c'est
c'est quelle marque ? Je sais pas. Je
vais regarder. Les chinois, ils
regardent ce type de marque. C'est c'est
une chinoise. Ça s'appelle swatch. C'est
le truc
le euh Non, non. Pour aller où ce
capitalisme prédateur ?
Alors, il est pas c'est pas seulement le
capitalisme, hein. C'est parce que
enfin, tout dépend ce que vous appelez
capitalisme, mais euh justement euh la
Chine a un modèle qui est très
différent. C'est pour ça qu'on est en
rivalité systémique. Ce second choc
chinois, c'est
l'innovation à faible
productivité, faible productivité du
travail et faible productive du capital.
Donc vous allez au salon de l'OTO à
Paris, je sais pas si vous y étiez, en
octobre, vous avez Renault qui sort une
R5 électrique 35000 €. Et le modèle de
luxe à 154000.
Modèle de luxe, il vient de sortir
154000. En face, vous avez BYD le
chinois qui dit si vous avez 35000 €
c'est le prix d'une BM en 2019, donc je
vous ai une BM. Puis si par hasard vous
gagnez 2000 € comme le salaire médiat en
France, j'ai l'équivalent de la 5
électrique mais à 10000 US.
mentionné. Alors ça vient de deux
choses. Ce que vous expliquent
les équipement automobiles, c'est qu'à
30 points de marge de différence. Pour
votre marge brute est de 20 %. Il y a un
écart de 30. Il y a on pense la moitié
qui vient de subvention gouvernementale,
donc 250 milliards de dollars cumulés
pour faire 30 millions de voitures en
Chine, à peu près 10000 US par donc ils
vont tuer tous les producteurs et
ensuite ils vont augmenter les prix. Ils
vont en garder euh 4 ou 5 et aujourd'hui
vous avez 50 marques. J'ai une question.
Et juste un petit truc, juste un petit
truc pour vous dire qu'on n'est pas
foutu, c'est que à 30 millions, vous
savez ce que je vous dis ? Qu'il y avait
que 100 millions de gens qui avaient de
l'argent, 100 millions avec papa, maman,
un enfant, ça fait 30 millions de
voitures. Donc le marché chinois, il est
pénétré à 100 %. La voiture électrique,
il y a 80 % des Français qui n'en
veulent pas. Donc on peut fermer le
marché pas l'acheter. Non, qui trouve
que c'est pas bien, qui trouve que les
c'est stressant, les bornes ne marchent
pas. C'est un enfer total donc j'en
veux. Et en plus, elle est beaucoup trop
cher donc j'en veux pas. Question
internet. Bonsoir monsieur Bavrez. Que
prévoyez-vous ? Alors, que prévoyez-vous
l'avenir de nos fleurons ? Je lis la
question. de nos fleurons français
spécialisés dans l'énergie air liquide
total NG dans cette incertitude
géopolitique et énergétique.
Ben c'est ce que raconte Total he
tourner une faiblesse en opportunité.
total est la seule majeur qui a pas de
pétrole dans son pays domestique. Donc
faut qu'on soit ce que vous expliquez
gens total, faut qu'on soit meilleur que
les autres partout dans le monde. Donc
je ne vois absolument pas pourquoi on
serait on
partirait forcément perdu. Je veux pas
être arrogant, on va pas gagner d'avance
mais on n'est pas pas du tout perdu
d'avance. Enfin Total est la meilleure
major de tous les rapports d'analyse
financier que je lis. Total est la
meilleure mur regardez BPI le chairman
vient encore de sauter cette boîte BPI
est gérée n'importe comment ils ont
paumé 20 milliards en Russie le
lendemain de la Russie ils ont dit on
offre 20 milliards gratos au russes
enfin c'est n'importe quoi. Incapable de
faire la transition environnementale
totale à une feuille de route qui est
parfaite. Écoutez le l'audition de
Pouyanis au Sénat il y a 9 mois c'est un
c'est un bijou. C'est pas moi qui faut
écouter c'est Pouyan au Sénat. Patrick
on te dit
bonjour. L'Afrique vous avez vous portez
quel regard sur l'Afrique ? Alors
l'Afrique, j'ai l'immense bonheur d'être
un des principaux actionnaires de
Sagassi Research qui est la première
société de recherche en consommateur
africain où on est présent dans 10 pays
sur les 54.
Donc j'allais dire affectivement,
intellectuellement, j'adore l'Afrique.
Ayant dit ça,
malheureusement
la décennie qui vient
où la Chine exporte ses excédents de
capacité industrielle à perte. Ce qui
fait que il est impossible de développer
du manufacturing dans un pays émergent
si vous avez un chinois en face de vous
et que Chat GPT fait et toute la
l'intelligence artificielle générative
fait que les services à basse valeur
ajoutée vont être très automatisés. Le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'il faut qu'on
prenne un agriculteur Kenyan et qu'on
lui dise tu es des tasses un tsh chez
Google où tu n'as pas d'avenir. Donc
malheureusement je pense que les
tensions elles vont être est- ouest avec
le découpling dont je vous ai parlé ce
découplage entre Chine et Amérique qui
va être beaucoup plus violent que ce à
quoi je m'attendais. Mais les tensions
elles vont être encore plus nord- sud et
le plus gros cadeau que Donald Trump en
100 jours vient de faire à la Chine
c'est de lui offrir tout ce qu'on
appelle le sud global.
sur un plateau parce que tous ces pays
que les États-Unis ont taxé à 45 50 90 %
Pékin appelé le lendemain disant vous
voyez qu'on est gentil. Donc nous nous
avons un regard totalement méprisant sur
le sud global en disant mais ça a aucune
cohérence économique, ça va nulle part,
c'est n'importe quoi. Ce qui est vrai
économiquement, mais on ne se rend pas
compte que comme il n'y aura pas de
modèle économique, il va y avoir une
cohésion politique et que cette cohésion
politique, si on ne se réveille pas,
elle va faire le jeu de la Chine alors
que c'est la Chine qui en grande partie
les empêche de se manufacturer.
Vous connaissez très bien l'Asie du
Sud-Est.
Alors, je connais pas très bien, mais il
se trouve que j'étais il y a 3 semaines
à Singapour en train de faire une
conférence et que j'ai pu discuter avec
les 10 pays de l'Azéan. Alors, ça, on
peut en parler. Quand je vous ai dit
qu'à 27, vous êtes incapable de prendre
une décision. L'Azéan, c'est quoi ?
L'Azéan, c'est 10 pays. Ce sont 10
pays
culturellement beaucoup plus différents
que les 10 pays européens.
Il y a la mer qui les sépare. Les
régimes politiques sont totalement
différents. Ils s'entendent sur un truc,
la sécurité contre la Chine. On a une
communaité d'intérêt, c'est que la Chine
est une menace. Au-delà de ça, c'est
dossier par dossier. J'arrive qui même
me
suivent. Et c'est l'exemple qu'on a chez
nous, c'est Agè Runier Pach Panier
Runaché. le nucléaire. Les Allemands
mettent le droit de véto en disant
"C'est hors de question que vous avez un
avantage compétitif incroyable, il faut
le tuer. Donc il y aura pas de nucléaire
en Europe." Et elle y est allé a dit "Tu
même me suivent ?" Rien à [__] du véto
allemand. A dit d'autres alors je sais
pas mais elle a dit aussi il nous faut
100000 personnes dans le nucléaire d'ici
2030. Ouais voyez là on va s'y mettre.
Donc il y a 10 pays qu'on dit oui, ils
entourent tous l'Allemagne. Donc le
nucléaire soit ça marche et on va avoir
de l'électricité qu'on va vendre,
j'espère une fortune à
l'Allemagne et ça va nous permettre de
financer d'autres trucs. Soit ça pète et
si ça pète chez nous, ben l'Allemagne il
y aura droit aussi. Donc c'est pas mal.
Vous voyez le comme d' c'est plutôt
malin. Et comment comment vous concevez
le le réchauffement climatique en Asie
du Sud-Est ? Une température qui
augmente, un taux d'humidité à plus de
90 %.
Alors le beaucoup énergétique pour la
clime
difficile une des alors j'ai la question
surtout à propos de la
Chine qui est 30 % des CO2
mondiaux et un consommateur chinois
c'est 5000 dollars par an en moyenne. Un
consommateur américain c'est 50000
dollars par an en moyenne. Et les
États-Unis disent à la Chine faudrait
quand même que tu changes de style de
vie et que tu arrêtes de
polluer. Donc ça ça va
passer. Et
donc la bonne nouvelle comme je vous ai
dit, c'est qu'au premier trimestre, la
capacité installée des renouvelables en
Chine est supérieure aux énergies
fossiles. La production est inférieure
parce que ça met plus de temps.
Mais la Chine, je pense, elle fait pas
ça pour être gentille, pour sauver la
planète, c'est qu'elle a compris que
c'était l'avantage compétitif du 20e
siècle. Je vous ai dit qu'en 2050, vos
petits-enfants euh seront devant la
Chine Arabie Saoudite de 1973.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'intelligence artificielle ?
Alors euh je suis pas du tout
spécialiste. Mon c'est vraiment un gut
feeling de donc c'est mes tripes he
d'investisseur c'est que ça va être
extraordinaire mais c'est 75 80 c'est ça
met 5 ans à délivrer. Donc Bill Gates a
inventé
l'ordinateur en 75 et ça a délivré à
partir de 1980. Donc c'est la manière de
C'est Bill Gates qui a inventé c'est
pardon il a pas piqué l'idée à quelqu'un
d'autre ? Non. Ouais non. Bref. On
s'entend. Euh, il était peut-être pas
tout seul mais bref, ils ont réussi au
bout de 5 ans. Donc là, nous avons je
pense 5 années, je vous dis ça comme ça,
hein, 5 années de stackflation et qui on
va s'en sortir par
l'intelligence artificielle générative.
Maintenant, vous regardez les chiffres
de CAPG minini annoncé hier. Euh
l'intelligence artificielle, la manière
dont ça va se répandre, c'est par les
boîtes d'IT services. Donc c'est
regarder Action Tour et Capier mini. Si
vous voulez savoir à quel point ça
pénètre dans les boîtes. Les résultats
d'hier, c'est 6
% du carnet de commande. C'est en hausse
de 6 % d'année en année. Donc c'est très
très lent. Et la raison pour laquelle
c'est très simple, c'est que ça ne
marche pas. Et je veux pas être négatif.
Ça marche pas parce que le truc
hallucine et que vous pouvez pas vous
avez le ce qu'on appelle le CTO donc le
chef de la technologie de JP Morgan hier
qui a dit je suis extrêmement nerveux de
nos clients industriels
qui sont en train d'utiliser cette
intelligence artificielle qui ne me
maîtrise pas.
Donc c'est juste que c'est trop tôt.
Vous savez, c'est Bill
Gates, vous surestimez les 12 prochains
mois, vous sous-estimez les 12
prochaines années. L'intelligence
artificielle générative, c'est
exactement ça. Donc soyons patient, on
va avoir la vallée de la mort. Vous
savez que Microsoft actuellement est en
train d'annuler ces giga center de data
center aux US parce que pour l'instant
ça ne délivre pas. Mais ça veut pas dire
que donc on a des attentes beaucoup trop
élevées nous
investisseurs. On va avoir une petite
vallée de la mort et puis on finira mais
quand ? On va voir c'est ce qui va nous
occuper tous les trimestres. Question
internet prospective, elle ressemblera à
quoi la France dans 10 ans ? Faillite,
pas faillite, son économie, fédéralisme
européen ?
Ça c'est une bonne question. Alors, je
suis pas je suis pas madame Soleil et il
y a que de l'espoir dans ce que je vais
dire. Euh mais l'espoir c'est que cette
liberté d'agir et cette liberté de
penser, on a retrouvé l'ADN de nos
grands-pères qu'on fait en 1951, la
communauté d'acier et du charbon. Et
donc on va utiliser ça pour produire des
biens des services que l'ensemble de la
planète nous veut. Et on a une carte à
jouer incroyable. Donc je pense que oui,
pour répondre à la question, il faudra
que ce soit panne européen parce queon
va avoir en face de nous la Chine et les
US. Donc il faut qu'on travaille à
diviser la Chine. Pour moi, il y a pas
une Chine, il y a deux Chines. Il y a la
Chine des entrepreneurs privés, du
capital privé qui a peu près 50 % de
l'économie avec lesquels on bosse depuis
20 ans et avec lesquels on a une
commalité d'intérêt totale. Et puis il y
a l'autre Chine qui sont des
néoléninomarxistes avec lesquels on est
en réalité systémique. Et là on a une
chance incroyable, c'est que comme les
États-Unis veulent dévaluer le dollar,
la Chine veut dévaluer sa monnaie. Donc
les entrepreneurs privés chinois pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps sont
invités à sortir leurs capitaux de
Chine. Et donc quand vous m'avez posé la
question sur l'Asie du Sud-Est, on peut
aller ensemble dans les 10 prochaines
années ensemble en Asie Sud-aise qui est
aujourd'hui entre les mains de la
diaspora chinoise. 90 % des
milliardaires en Asie du
Sud-Estorine. Donc on y va avec eux en
disant notre ennemi commun ce sont les
néolinomarxistes. Notre commalité
d'intérêt, c'est de continuer ce qu'on a
fait pendant 20 ans. Les États désunis
amé les États désunis, je rappelle que
Trump n'a pas été élu avec 100 % des
voix. Donc il faut arrêter. Il était élu
avec 51, je sais pas combien 50 52 % des
voies, ce qui veut dire qu'il y a des
contrepouvoirs. On doit travailler tous
les contrepouvoirs. Mais poser une
question sur l'énergie. Le jour où Trump
a annoncé qu'il sortait de l'accord de
Paris, c'est le premier truc qu'il a
fait le premier jour. Le lendemain, 24
États ont dit qui représentent 55 % de
la population américaine, 60 % du PNB
américain ont dit "Nous restons dans
l'accord de Paris." Donc en matière
énergétique, l'éolien offshore
effectivement il dépend du fédéral donc
il est mort. Mais le reste le solaire
l'éolien onsore, il dépend des États. On
continue comme avant. Je rappelle que
Trump 1.0, il y a jamais eu autant
d'augmentation d'énergie renouvelable en
Chine. Donc on le dit, on a les États
les contrepouvoirs, on se les fait un
par un. On a les gouverneurs
républicains, on a les universités, on a
les juges, on a les GAFA qui sont contre
la République technologique de la bande
de PayPal. On a tout un tas de
contrepouvoirs qui sont dans notre camp.
On bosse avec eux. les États, on ne
parle plus jamais d'États-Unis, on ne
parle que des États désunis et on les
divise. C'est ce que la Chine fait avec
nous. Est- que vous Et au contraire, on
s'unit. Est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté ?
Dernière question, dépêchez-vous, hein.
J'ai euh Non, j'ai pas trois livres.
Non, j'ai d'abord j'ai un conseil qui
est Alors, trois livres à nous
conseiller. Alors, on va commencer. J'ai
un conseil qui le conseil c'est vous
vous coupez de Facebook, vous vous
coupez d'Insta et vous gagnez 2 heures
par jour pour lire. Ça c'est le premier
conseil.
Alors, vous les trois bouquins euh sur
la Chine, là où
j'habite, euh alors je vous dire un
bouquin traditionnel, c'est Kissinger on
China, donc de la Chine. Un bouquin
culturel génial, c'est Dragon Tactics de
Sandrin Zerbip qui vous explique le de
manière géniale le pourquoi le
management chinois est fantastique.
C'est personne qui a monté Adidas de 0 à
1 milliard en Chine. C'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extraordinaire. Et puis
alors pour vous marier, puisquil faut se
marrer dans la vie, vous lisez Red
Roulette. C'est c'est peut-être traduit
par roulette rouge, je sais pas en
français. Euh qui est la vie de Madame
30 %, je vous en dis pas plus. Les vrais
bouquins en dehors de la Chine. Euh bah
la Bible, la Bible, je vous l'ai déjà
cité, c'est la connaissance inutile de
Jean-François Ruel qui est écrit avant
les réseaux sociaux. Donc voyez les
billets cognitifs c'est sur
l'information c'est pour moi ça reste
l'un des livres qui m'a le plus marqué.
Un petit pitch, pardon ? Un petit pitch.
Ben un petit pitch et que si vous voulez
face au fake news, l'avalanche de fake
news, roulet chinoise, la roulette
chinoise, pardon. Euh bah le seul truc
qui nous reste, c'est le le seul truc
que les réseaux sociaux ne ont pas nous
bouffer, c'est le libre arbitre. C'est
chaque fois qu'il y a une news quand je
vous dis ça fait de mois un mois et demi
qu'on me parle de tarif et c'est
n'importe quoi. Bon ben, c'est parce que
j'ai refusé l'info en disant ce qu'il
raconte est n'importe quoi. Alors que
tout le monde me parle de tarif. Et puis
alors pour finir euh ça c'est un bouquin
que j'ai lu récemment et que j'ai adoré
qui est euh
Homocretinus euh le triomphe de la
bêtise de
Olivier Postelvinet avec la définition
de la bêtise de Jean Kilevic. Euh la
bêtise c'est s'en tenir là peu importe
où. Vous saviez vous savez et ça je
trouve ça génial. Vous savez ce que
disait Jacques Brell ? Il disait plein
de trucs sur la bêtise.
Je me souviens pas de celle-là. Et ben,
vous irez chercher. Est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour les jeune génération ?
Ah non, moi je vais une question plus
personnelle avant ça. Votre poète
préféré ? Mon poète
préféré euh et un verre qui va avec.
Le bah c'est le verre à boire hein,
c'est mon préféré. Donc est-ce que vous
avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Une bouteille à la mer.
Ouais.
Euh c'est mon premier mon premier
bouquin. C'est Mccafi, propesseur of
MIT. Parce que a il y a l'autre.
Faut-il
protéger le passé du
futur ou le futur du passé ? Donc ayez 3
ans d'âge mental. tout raisonnement,
toute personne qui vous parle d'un truc
avant 2022, faites l'inverse et je
compléterai par qui ne connaît pas son
passé finisser la phrase n'a pas de
futur et condamné à le revivre David
Bavrez. Merci c'est moi. Un grand merci.
[Musique]